de campagne c'est parti
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames et messieurs bons
dimanches matins je vous suggère
d'allonger votre café on vous propose
une émission
toute la matinée jusqu'en début d'après
midi sébastien bovet bonjour et vous
prendrait le relais cet après midi avec
vos mordu c'est une programmation
spéciale pourquoi parce que oui on en
parle beaucoup de cette campagne
électorale mais elle est lancée
officiellement ce matin monsieur legault
va se rendent chez le lieutenant
gouverneur va demander que l'assemblée
que la législature soit dissoute et que
donc les députés redeviennent des
candidats pour leur parti les ministres
restent ministres l'exécutif du
gouvernement continue mais l'assemblée
législative
est dissoute sébastien les gens puis
encore hier est quelqu'un que m'arrêter
je faisais des courses puis dire oui
mais monsieur roy c'est décidé attention
oui bien sûr que la caq commence avec
une avancée extraordinaire
mais je disais hier à des gens puis la
semaine dernière dans nos émissions il y
aura des débats réels lors de cette
campagne électorale le coût de la vie y
est le coût de la vie inquiète c'est une
chose qui tombèrent et un gab le coût de
la vie inquiète la santé inquiète
j'aurai à montréal hier un sondage est
peut-être vu les québécois estiment que
monsieur legault à
annappes a réussi à livrer ce qu'il
avait promis un santé est une évidence
j'allais me dire donc c'est un processus
réel important dans une démocratie
commence aujourd'hui rappelez vous de
2015 justin trudeau parts et 3e dans sa
campagne à lille a fini premier donc les
campagnes électorales veulent dire
quelque chose trois choses là dessus
monsieur legault est en avance oui mais
c'est parce que l'opposition face à lui
est morcelé en quatre parties qui
veulent son sa job qui veulent de
prendre le pouvoir donc sa mort celle là
l'opposition françois legault et son
pire ennemi aussi il est jamais loin
d'une pelure de banane qui peut le faire
trébucher aussi donc il faut faire
attention est comment les électeurs vont
se comporter aussi est-ce que ils vont
aller voter sachant qu'il est si on
avance dans les sondages aussi autant de
questions qu'on se pose sur la ligne de
départ et le phénomène 2018 les vieux
partis
qui ont pris une débarque est ce que
tout ça se confirme ce qu'il ya un ré
alignement pour un autre mandat bon
c'est ce genre de questions première
fois mesdames et messieurs que il ya
cinq partis qui sont en mesure de faire
élire au moins un député d'ailleurs il y
aura cinq chefs lors du débat des chefs
on va faire un tour d'horizon avec ses
bastides et région où vous habitez qu'on
surveille en fait on veut sauver poma
tout il ya des endroits fort intéressant
on va aller sur le terrain également les
journalistes nos journalistes vont
suivre les chefs pendant toute la durée
de cette campagne on est très content de
ça parce que vous serez du jour a
aujourd'hui au jour 36 on va poser des
questions lors des points de presse
on sait que de plus en plus les
meilleurs se repose sur ce qui arrive
dans les salles des nouvelles la
conférence de presse qui arrive qui est
enregistrée vous serez là pour poser des
questions alors vous les voyez on va
tout au long de la matinée avec leur
chef avec leur chef présenter les
conférences de presse je vous dis tout
de suite le pour ceux qui aiment avoir
une idée de l'horaire de la matinée vers
8h30 monsieur legault sera un conseil
des ministres
donc petit discussions ponctuées virtuel
il se rend chez monsieur doyon le
lieutenant-gouverneur ensuite et demande
donc la dissolution de l'assemblée et
ensuite les points de presse
traditionnelle des parties 10 heures
madame à anglade 11 heures monsieur
legault dans la région de québec paul st
pierre plamondon est prévu à 11h45 12h30
monsieur duhaime du parti conservateur
et ils ferment la marche dans les points
de presse le chef du parti québécois
paul st pierre plamondon autour de 13h
donc s'en va tous vos présentations bois
13 heures à 13 heures ou qu'est ce que
j'ai dit par exemple j'ai vraiment aimé
alors gabriel nadeau-dubois 13h ses
points de presse vous seront données en
direct entièrement évidemment avec les
questions des journalistes et nous
analyse chantal hébert alec castonguay
je vous dis bonjour merci d'être là
bonjour jour le partager notre café
politique qui voit là ce matin corps
c'est parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de choses au menu un petit tour de table
rapide
bien sûr que la caq part avec une forte
avance mais il ya des choses fort
intéressante à surveiller dans cette
campagne chanteur
vous avez parlé de cinq parties vous
allez vous y habituer vite parce que
c'est ce qu'on voit à ottawa depuis déjà
un bon bout de temps cinq parties est ce
que ça a donné je fais pas une
prédiction pour cette année mais ce que
ça a donné c'est sur cette campagne
fédérale d'un gouvernement majoritaire
est autrement minoritaires minoritaires
minoritaires sauf s'il n'a pas su justin
trudeau donc c'est une dynamique
différente et on semble depuis déjà tous
que dix ans
de redécoupage de la carte électorale ou
de la dynamique électorale au québec
dans la mesure où pour une majorité
d'électeurs la question nationale et la
question constitutionnelle les deux
allant de pair sont mis de côté le
véhicule parti libéral on peut réussir
je serai présent trouver leur place dans
ce nouvel ordre des choses alors très
intéressant de voir au bout de la course
où on en sera dans cette transition qui
selon moi est encore en course et pas
s'est pas fixé définitivement encore
alec toutes les campagnes électorales
disent quelque chose sur l'endroit où on
est rendu comme société alors que ce
soit
la santé du pq des libéraux à éric
duhaime offert une percée québec
solidaire poursuivre sa progression ça
dit quelque chose de où nous en sommes
collectivement donc il ya des courses
très intéressante à suivre qui vont pour
les quatre prochaines années une fois le
résultat connu avoir une influence
importante alors au site une campagne
qui compte pour tous les partis
politiques pour ne pas uniquement pour
savoir qui va être le gouvernement mais
également qu'elle va être la dynamique à
l'assemblée nationale dynamique avec des
bottes société c'est pas du tout la même
chose si le pq maintient sa force aussi
le thomas un député même chose si éric
duhaime en fait les uns ou enfin les
recettes c'est pas la même dynamique
nous a plu alors il va y avoir une
influence importante sur la suite des
choses très bien et on va faire le tour
des régions conservées dans son instinct
mais je le disais nous allons suivre de
a à z cette campagne électorale sur le
terrain je vais faire une tournée avec
ses journalistes que vous avez entre vu
tout à l'heure alexandre duval vous êtes
avec la cac on avait rogné princes avec
le parti libéral jacques audrey
charbonneau avec québec solidaire et
valérie gamache avec le parti québécois
sébastien desrosiers avec le parti
conservateur donc on est et je le
souligne de plus de trois fois les gens
me disent une évidence non ce n'est pas
au niveau d'un oui pour la la télé
publique on a une responsabilité mais
beaucoup de médias de plus en plus c'est
plus comme à l'époque moi où je couvrais
des campagnes tous les médias étaient
dans le sens qu'on appelle les autobus
de a à z ce n'est plus le cas pourquoi
pas ça coûte une fortune
je commence avec vous alexandre duval
avec la caq donc monsieur legault
sébastien le disait
conseil des ministres virtuel il sera
chez le lieutenant gouverneur puis on
part ça aux chutes de moments si je
crois
absolument écouter c'est un peu le
protocole en ce que vous voyez à tous
les quatre ans lorsqu'une élection est
déclenchée best avec monsieur legault
qu'on le vit ce matin pour nous situer
on est bien entendu à québec derrière
l'hôtel du parlement et là vous le voyez
derrière moi et l'yonne l'autobus du
chef qui est prêt à partir avec le
slogan continuons monsieur legault qui
est bien mise en évidence et bien mise
en évidence sur cet autobus de campagne
alors oui la première étape c'est ce
conseil des ministes adoption des
décrets qui permettront le déclenchement
des élections ensuite monsieur legault
va faire une petite marche sur cette rue
vous voyez la vue des parlementaires il
sera accompagné de sa femme il rencontré
le lieutenant gouverneur et c'est là
qu'on demandera la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale la toute fin
pratique c'est une formalité et puis
ensuite de son premier arrêt vers 11h ce
matin on aura une première véritable
l'allocution de monsieur leubou répondra
aux questions des journalistes et
ensuite on prendre la route du saguenay
il y aura une arête dans une entreprise
du saguenay et ensuite on se rend en fin
de journée dans la circonscription de
jonquière et c'est pas du tout anodin ce
choix de la circonscription de jonquière
comme premier gros rassemblement
militant parce que jean-pierre pas
triste c'est la seule circonscription au
sec n'y échappe toujours à la coalition
avenir québec à l'heure actuelle et elle
est bien d'encercler sur la carte
électorale des stratèges caquistes on
veut aller chercher jean pierre on vise
un balayage du saguenay cette année et
on croit que c'est possible parce que le
député sortant sylvain gaudreault du
parti québécois ne se représente pas il
avait remporté cette circonscription la
avec 48% des voix en 2008 majorité d'à
peu près 5000 voix ce qui était
considérable mais là la caq considère
qu'elle est compétitive cette année dans
jonquière je vous rappelle que monsieur
leubou à plusieurs reprises dans les
derniers mois ont parlé du fait qu'ils
voulaient décrocher une majorité lors de
cette élection mais une majorité forte
et ça implique que monsieur legault doit
faire des gains dans plusieurs régions
et c'est pour ça qu'on s'arrête au
saguenay pour commencer cette campagne
est
aujourd'hui avec monsieur legault ne
vous attendez pas à des annonces
électorale ne vous attendez pas à des
promesses puisque monsieur legault me
propose aujourd'hui c'est un
démonstration de force aux saguenéens
coup rassemblement tout senti beaucoup
les promesses ça commencera demain c'est
très parlant ça dit beaucoup qui partent
au saguenay sébastien vous montrer la
carte c'est encore plus clair là où il
ya des du rouge sur la carte l'a4 qui
est dans une logique offensive on n'est
pas dans le défend nous à qui on est d'à
on prend de l'ampleur et jonquière c'est
une très bonne exempt d'ivoire où tu
vois je te dirai ce que tu veux faire
dans une campagne électorale c'est très
symbolique que monsieur legault quand sa
campagne électorale au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean voici la carte
du saguenay-lac-saint-jean résultats de
2018 donc ne vous méprenez pas roberval
ici avait élu philippe couillard mais
attention
depuis ce temps là ça me prend des gros
doigts ça a été peint peinture et en
bleu cac la caq a remporté cette
circonscription donc en ce moment
roberval et de couleurs cac et la
circonscription de jonquière c'est
difficile à voir mais les jeux c'est ici
dans un petit bleu ici c'est le député
sortant monsieur
gaudreault qui a été élu dans la
circonscription de jonquière donc ça
c'est une circonscription péquiste on
parlera un peu plus tard de l'est parce
qu'on voit beaucoup de ces constructions
pays qu à l'est mais au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean il n'en reste
plus qu'une et c'est celle de
jean-pierre oui on voit rené lévesque
gaspé envoie matin
madame atpdh ya pire monsieur bérubé
doit en avoir assez qu'on répète c'est
peut-être la seule circonscription que
le pq une garde robe on verra mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que la cac est à
l'offensive dans l'est du québec
beaucoup oui et dans l'est du québec il
faut s'attendre à rimouski notamment au
québec solidaire la caq ont des visées
sur cette circonscription le député
sortant harold lebel du pq élu sous la
bannière du pq mais indépendant ne se
représente pas on aura l'occasion d'un
repas très bien je vais je vais
poursuivre ma tournée avec nos journées
sur le terrain véronique presse vous
partez cette campagne avec le parti
libéral
c'est à québec au parlement c'est là que
démarre les libéraux
oui et moi je me trouve devant le bureau
du lieutenant-gouverneur parce que je
vais assister en direct lorsque monsieur
legault va arriver tout à l'heure ce que
je fais à l'intérieur ici et oui après
je monte dans l'autobus libéral vous
avez raison de dire que c'est très
important de voir à quel endroit les
chefs se rendent en premier parce que
c'est un message qui est lancé on veut
aussi mettre le chef en valeur on veut
un endroit où on va avoir des beaux
décors on avoir beaucoup de militants
pour justement être démarré la campagne
sur le bon pied du côté dominique
anglade elle va se rendre sans surprise
à montréal dans l'est de montréal parce
qu'il faudrait que les libéraux auraient
quand même l'embarras du choix est-ce
qu'il devrait aller dans un comté plus
anglophone ou un compte et avec des
votes francophones mais je pense que la
réponse est évidente parce que lorsqu'on
regarde les dernières intentions de vote
lorsqu'on regarde le portrait en général
ils ont perdu beaucoup de vote
francophone et faut essayer de le
récupérer c'est un des très gros défi
une grande pente à remonter pour
dominique anglade durant toute cette
campagne électorale la est donc en
débutant dans l'est de montréal elle
s'en va dans le comté de lafontaine la
fontaine y en a là bas beaucoup de
francophones s'est entouré par exemple
des circonscriptions de bourges est en
fait dans le coin de rivière des
prairies pointe aux trembles alors ça
vous donne une idée de landreau s'est
situé et le député la bob marc
lafontaine
avait gagné par une majorité imposante
excusez-moi marc tanguay c'est marc
tanguay le député libéral là-bas et sa
majorité était un peu son champagne
électorale il avait gagné
il avait gagné par un vague mais il voit
la dernière fois et la particularité de
marc tanguay c'est que c'est un trooper
comment dit alors c'est quelqu'un qui
est capable de galvaniser les troupes
jusqu'à la période de questions là c'est
toujours lui qui parle le plus fort
c'est lui qui est théâtral alors il va
être capable de livrer un discours pour
présenter sa chair il va gonfler les
militants à bloc il faut dire que c'est
une des circonscriptions libérales où il
ya encore beaucoup de bénévoles parce
que ça c'est un déficit pour les partis
politiques d'avoir encore des bénévoles
sur le terrain encore des militants qui
vont dans les rassemblements et donc on
pense qu'à cet endroit il y aura
tellement de libéraux que ça va
permettre à dominique anglade d'être
revigoré énergisé parce qu'elle en a
grandement besoin avant cette campagne
électorale parce que c'est difficile
pour tous les partis d'opposition en ce
moment véronique merci on va se parler
très souvent merci beaucoup jacques
audrey charbonneau et vous êtes devant
l'autobus de campagne de québec
solidaire à berri uqam il vous partez en
direction de sherbrooke
sherbrooke voilà pourquoi sherbrooke
pourquoi pour québec solidaire c'est une
région importante l'esprit en général
mais on veut attaquer sur deux fronts en
fait d'abord conserver les acquis
défendre les acquis de québec solidaire
entre autres dans la circonscription de
sherbrooke avec kristine labrie en 2018
qui avait un peu causer la surprise
cette année elle affronte la cahc christ
caroline st-hilaire ex mairesse de
longueuil donc ça risque d'être une
lutte intéressante mais d'autre part on
veut faire des gains en estrie du côté
de québec solidaire dans l'équipe ici de
québec solidaire ont dit on aimerait
faire tache d'huile en estrie parce
qu'on juge qu'on a des bonnes assises et
que donc dans la circonscription dans
laquelle on sera aujourd'hui où sera
déclenché la campagne de québec
solidaire à saint-françois donc la
circonscription voisine qui englobe une
partie la ville de sherbrooke et bien on
présente la candidate mélissa généreux
eux donc la docteure ancienne directrice
de la santé publique régionale c'est une
candidature vedette peut-on dire pour
québec solidaire étant donné qu'elle
jouit d'une certaine notoriété au niveau
régional et national même peut-on dire
et également parce qu'elle jouit d'une
crédibilité aussi c'est là dessus qu'on
veut marteler un peu le message de
québec solidaire on veut montrer qu'on a
pris de l'expérience qu'on a pris du
galon et qu'on peut donc aspirer à
croître encore parce que depuis 2008 je
vous le rappelle aux élections du québec
solidaire n'a fait que croître et donc
c'est là dessus qu'on veut est misé au
cours de cette campagne on a divisé
ailleurs dans le coin de montréal
également en région donc on va se
promener aussi l'autre côté de québec
solidaire très bien pour nous l'occasion
de se reparler bien sûr merci beaucoup
bonbonnes campagne bonne campagne avoue
sébastien
prenons les deux les deux régions
d'abord l'estrie sherbrooke c'est sur la
liste à peu près tout le monde comme sa
construction à surveiller ouais et une
bataille à prévoir entre la coalition
avenir québec et le la colle québec
solidaire parce que c'est une
circonscription solidaire avec kristine
labrie qui a beaucoup marqué de points à
l'assemblée nationale mais qui fait face
à caroline st-hilaire donc une vraie
date d'une vedette une candidate vedette
de la coalition avenir québec saint
françois dont nous parlait jacobé c'est
juste à côté ici c'est une
circonscription bleus cas qu'en fait
vous voyez il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
grand chose à part du bleu sur
sherbrooke avec caroline st-hilaire les
gens de la caq espère un tueur et la
question de cette région la peinture et
bleu l'ensemble de l'estrie c'est un
prince ça va être intéressant aussi avec
la directrice de santé publique qui se
présentent dans cette circonscription
pour québec solidaire montréal remet
témoin la grande région de montréal
parce qu'habituellement ou dix c'est
beaucoup la région de québec ce lait du
québec qu'on surveille les strips en
labo la région de montréal est fort
intéressant oui parce que ça bouge pas
ou presque pas la région montréal
c'était une affaire assez régler les
libéraux dans l'ess dans l'ouest le
parti québécois dans l'est pour
certaines circonscriptions mais là vous
voyez que la banque leur hausse et les
résultats évidemment de 2018 donc le
rouge libéral est bien présent mais le
orange commence à faire des percées est
ici dans l'est la pointe-de-l'île la caq
a réussi à faire déborder sur l'île des
circonscriptions notamment bourget et
pointe aux trembles tout alain véronique
nous parlait de la fontaine c'est la
circonscription qui est juste là donc
voyez c'est ce qu' ils sont à l' attaque
là ils sont tatoués également
aujourd'hui réel ou lise thériault la
députés ne se représentent pas la crêpe
en fait sur l'île de montréal ce qui est
intéressant aussi dans les
circonscriptions à surveiller c'est le
sud ici de l'île de montréal il ya
quelques circonscriptions qui sont à
surveiller notamment celle de
madame
madame anglade la chef du parti libéral
la circonscription quitte ici c'est
henri sainte anne madame anglade
pourrait être en difficulté dans sa
propre circonscription québec solidaire
et le la coalition avenir québec ont
divisés sur cette circonscription juste
à côté verdun ausy qui est libéral les
légendes la coalition avenir québec et
québec solidaire ont divisé le dessus et
même marque est semble-t-il la
circonscription de enrico ciccone ou la
cac et québec solidaire ont des visites
là dessus donc se sépare l'île de
montréal ça pourrait bouger
maurice richard aussi peut-être ici
avant du gssa peu bougé
ce qui n'est pas fréquent comprenez que
sur l'île de montréal c'est la même
chose que pour l'ensemble du québec
québec solidaire essayer d'avoir de
nouvelles circonscriptions la cac et
c'est d'avoir de nouvelles
circonscriptions les libéraux c'est de
sauver les meubles essentiellement sur
l'île de montréal un peu comme dans la
réalité leur jacky garder leurs acquis
aussi très bien valérie gamache vous
êtes avec le parti québécois à montréal
justement on vienne après dans ce cas
mais je ne vous
absolument l autobus donc du parti
québécois qui est stationné à l'ombre
vraiment du mode du stade olympique
depuis hier soir et donc sur le coup de
10 heures 45 pour st pierre plamondon
doit se présenter ici monter à bord de
l'autobus pour se rendre dans sa
circonscription circonscription de
bourges et qui deviendra là au moment du
déclenchement des élections un peu plus
tard cet avant midi officiellement elle
est reconstruction camille-laurin donc
c'est hautement symbolique que pour
repousser pierre plamondon de se
présenter dans cette circonscription où
le père donc de la loi 101 a été élu à
quatre reprises sans voix un message du
saint pierre paul st pierre plamondon le
message que morial doit rester une ville
francophone et donc que le chef du parti
québécois doit se faire élire sur l'île
de montréal hautement symbolique parce
que le français ce sera un thème de la
campagne demande du parti québécois tout
comme l'indépendance mais je dois vous
dire que l'objectif est la plus grande
préoccupation au sein des troupes
péquistes actuellement c'est vraiment de
faire augmenter le nombre de députés à
l'assemblée nationale
ils étaient sept à la fin de la dernière
session parlementaire il y en a
seulement trop d'entre eux qui se
présente on pense à pascal bérubé et
mégane guérite mélenchon mais également
joël arsenault aux îles de la madeleine
alors là vraiment on a une équipe de
nouveau candidat je vous dirais on est
quand même arrivé affiché complet il ya
125 candidats qui se présenteront à
travers le québec pour le parti
québécois mais vous verrez les anciens
députés s'impliquer dans cette campagne
là et je pense que ta vie rené qui vont
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce sera notre
premier arrêt donc de camille laurin on
se rendra à joliette en soirée pour un
premier rassemblement péquistes ou
véronique hivon sort alors aux côtés de
paul st pierre plamondon évidemment aux
côtés de la candidate dans joliette
véronique venky donc reprendre le
flambeau de cette circonscription
vous verrez aussi peut-être lorsque nous
irons dans l'est martin ouellette député
d'un évêque sauter aussi dans l'aventuré
et venir appuyer pour st pierre
plamondon cela dit les prochains jours
pour nous ça va se dérouler à montréal
parce que le chef veut se faire élire
veut se faire élire donc sur l'île et
pour ça bien comme il ya plus de députés
du parti québécois sur le moral il
voudra lancer le message que le parti
est bien présent ici il veut regagner le
coeur des montréalais dans bourget dans
l'est de la ville où il veut déloger la
caq se pose st-pierre plamondon merci
beaucoup à tout de suite merci à vous
je l'avais dit lors du lancement de deux
de nos nos activités arts du canada
électorale que nous aurons des merdes et
ex-maire pour être précis une mairesse
je voulais présente vous les connaissez
luc ferrandez est avec nous manon cyr
mairesse de chibougamau vous êtes
toujours je dois le souligner vous êtes
toujours mes rêves est au pouvoir et
registre la bombe ex maire de québec
qu'on a commencé à qui on a commencé à
parler cette semaine dans nos chroniques
bonjour à vous trois
aujourd'hui jour trois personnes qui
connaissent bien évidemment tout le
québec les dossiers du québec
connaissent bien le monde municipal qui
est devenu qui devient de plus en plus
on le voit là un contre pouvoir
politique donc c'est intéressant de vous
j'en entends je vous permets un tour de
table d'abord sur vous qu'est ce que
vous allez particulièrement oui vous
allez tout surveiller qu'est-ce que vous
avez particulièrement surveillé luc
ferrandez commence avec vous
il est même
très bruyant sur la question de
l'environnement c'est-à-dire de la
préservation du territoire il habille
lire
la carte n'a pas répondu est ce que pour
obtenir les millions dont ils ont besoin
pour protéger les boiseries numérique
reste tenace et mm100 salaunes qu'est ce
qu'on va voir la première pour le même
copié des critiques que le logement
social le logement social a été la
première annonce le de la caq ont
annoncé qu'ils se retiraient avec eux
onze mille nouveaux logements sociaux et
abordables
les maires demandent 22 mille pour la
cent du pib et surtout des programmes de
promotion pour du 2 mars familiale donc
est ce qu'il y aura est ce que les
demandes du monde municipal notamment
quant à l'aménagement du territoire la
protection ou dit seront entendus et
davantage entendue manon cyr bonjour
sont fait plaisir de vous parler vous
surveillez quoi dans cette campagne vous
mais moi je vais surveiller certainement
toutes les engagements par rapport à la
question du logement
justement les maires
les grandes villes sorti cette semaine
surtout sommet qui avait fait sur
l'habitation mais je vais en garder
aussi comment ça se passe dans
différentes régions du québec parce que
moi je te russe de voir ce qui se passe
est bon que démocratie
combien on va avoir deux caravanes qui
vont se connaît alors ça me laisse de
susciter aussi l'élection le taux de
participation et je pense
qu'effectivement on aura des enjeux à
discuter il faut se rappeler que près
d'un an on a toute une nouvelle
génération de main mais risque a été élu
qui avait une approche peut-être un peu
différente de ce qu'on voyait
traditionnellement par rapport aux anges
ou de sociétés de leur communauté leur
grande ville donc je pense à ma
d'intérêt sans suivre de ce côté là
régis labeaume
maltais faut pas surévaluer
parce qu'une fois que c'est parti on les
oublie beaucoup bouche pense que les
quatre partis d'opposition vont tenter
de faire plaisir à tous les matchs
québec mais que le premier c'est la
caisse ne bougeront porte sur les
questions fondamentales alors moi c'est
de la façon dont je le veux je pense
qu'elles ne fonctionnent de françois
desvaud par ailleurs c'est pas pour y
est qu'il est agent caire aujourd'hui ça
fonctionne c'est le vote nationaliste
françois legault doit s'assurer que deux
concernés ce votre qui est chez lui mais
surtout conserver le 29 pour ça des
nationalistes qu'il a chez lui mais qui
ont comme deuxième choix du pq alors
pour lui s'il ya là quelque chose de
très sensible et il va tenter aussi
d'aller grappiller sur ce qui reste de
votre nationalisme au pq pour lui c'est
là que ça se passe et je suis heureux
que de conserver
42% communauté dans les sondages je suis
très très heureux ben cheikh qui ne le
serait pas assez énorme y aurait eu
comme l'opposition on a parlé de chantal
plutôt fédéral et souverain ne joue pas
ou beaucoup moins il a pris là tout le
centre et comme s'il y avait plus
beaucoup de place pour les autres manon
et locle
ce qui me surprend mais ces skins sur
bras comme maxime b avec grosse envie
je vois
pas ce que
ses lauriers mais
ce qui m'a surpris c'est ma décision
à cherbourg
le rouleau
le look est excellent mais la star je
vais aller les attaques qui sont en
terrain avec une demi le daip ça me
semble pic de son attitude et notre sens
c'est ma façon de pâtir du goodwill il
pourrait lui faire mal enlevé avec la
fonderie horne et on l'a vu avec mauriac
à
250 millions us cette fois plus d'argent
que les premiers
dans chaque dossier tout qui n'est pas
terrible qu'un exemple ma peau by news
juste avant il ne laisse rien au hasard
donc ça vous étonne cette combativité là
alors que la victoire dit vouer et
presque dans la poche qui pourrait mais
c'est pas la nature de la becque lama
non c'est pas ça la nature la pop dont
on veut progresser on veut on on se sent
l'adéquation avec la grande majorité des
québécois m'annoncer mais surtout c'est
que je pense qu'on veut rien prendre
pour acquis d'ailleurs l'ensemble des
partis comme ça mais chez monsieur
legault est clair que ion une
combativité qu'un intérêt de vouloir
aller chercher plus de sièges
effectivement ça peut sembler paradoxal
mais avec la campagne qu'on va avoir je
pense que personne ne peut rien prendre
pour acquis tout ça et c'est pour ça que
il est peut-être plus combatif mais
c'est son tempérament je crois aussi
également ouais ok je pense que personne
par une loi qui régissent conclusion là
dessus mais je voudrais qu'on sache trop
conne et aux élections en lait parce
qu'elles sont à 9,6 mais moi je souhaite
ardemment qu'aux plus vraiment parler de
deux graves problèmes apporte la santé
qui sont éternels damas n'a que 25 ne
les préoccupe tant que ça les deux
problèmes majeurs qui n'est pas au bout
sur la rente est la meilleure et
logement il faut absolument qu'on avance
là-dessus l'embauchent le trou en disant
qu'on va donner vos consciences onze
mille logements sociaux pour ceux qui
ont été aux municipales n'est pas de
montrer que c'est pas si simple que ça
mais la main d'oeuvre il faut que je
fasse quelque chose qu'on peut pas
toujours dire que dans le fond va
s'organiser pour faire rêver les
handicapés et quand on fait travailler
mais les gens plus travailler les jeunes
de
ces tarifs ou qu'il fasse quelque chose
merci à vous trois à plus tard on aura
l'occasion de se reparler plus tard puis
vous serez avec nous lors de la soirée
je le dis tu es en présentiel pour
reprendre le mot à la mode sébastien
desrosiers bonjour vous allez suivre le
parti conservateur vous êtes devant
lequel électoral du chef éric duhaime
dans chauveau où il veut se faire élire
à québec
exactement on était à québec donc dans
la circonscription de chauveau c'est ici
que le chef du parti conservateur du
québec éric duhaime tente de se faire
élire l'encore patrice ce n'est pas un
choix qui a été fait au hasard oui c'est
une circonscription qui est détenu par
la coalition avenir québec depuis du v10
8 mais auparavant souvenez vous c'est un
fief adéquiste de l'action démocratique
du québec pour lequel parti pour lequel
a milité à travailler éric duhaime et
c'est une circonscription aussi où il ya
beaucoup de conservateurs autant au
niveau provincial confédéral d'ailleurs
vous savez que le parti conservateur
compte aujourd'hui plus de 50 mille
membres au québec alors qu'ils en
avaient à peu près 500 quand monsieur
duhaime est arrivé en poste il ya un an
et demi alors c'est genre de phénomène
qui lui fait dire qu'il a le vent dans
les voiles la question patrice est de
savoir est ce que le vent souffle assez
fort pour le pousser jusqu'à l'assemblée
nationale du québec vous savez que le
parti n'a jamais fait élire un député et
mise beaucoup sur la région de québec il
y aura des militants ici aujourd'hui
pour récupérer des affiches électorales
participer à une épluchette de blé
d'inde monsieur duhaime prend la parole
en mi journée autour de 12h30 vous
l'avez dit mais donc chauveau d'autres
circonscriptions dans la grande région
de québec dans la capitale nationale en
chaudière appalaches évidemment en
beauce une région où il veut faire tache
d'huile pour reprendre cette expression
sur la carte électorale donc fort à
parier que vous allez voir cet autobus
beaucoup dans la région au cours des
prochaines semaines cinq semaines très
bien alors je vous rappelle mesdames et
messieurs qu'à 8h30 on devrait voir le
premier ministre sortir et aller
rencontrer le michel doyon le lieutenant
gouverneur pour lui demander de
dissoudre l'assemblée législative donc
les députés seize des députés deviennent
des candidats un peu partout au québec
je reviens sur la région de québec sur
chauveau je vais me mettre toute la
gomme parce que lui évidemment son
objectif c'est qu'il y en ait un
peut-être deux peut-être trois ans
on rêve en tout cas à faire son entrée
officielle l'assemblée on a beaucoup
parlé du parti conservateur mais à 14 %
dans les intentions de vote selon les
sondages le chiffre est dopé par la
grande région de québec se dire qu'il ya
il a des racines dans la grande région
de québec chauveau notamment cette
circonscription adéquiste rappelez-vous
gérard deltell s'était fait élire dans
cette circonscription et la bosse aussi
beauce-nord beau sud sur la rive sud de
québec ce sont les trois
circonscriptions
sur le radar de des conservateurs mais
c'est trois ou quatre circonscriptions
au moment où on se parle évidemment la
campagne voudra dire quelque chose mais
c'est surtout dans la région de québec
qui est de la traction pour l'instant
pour le parti conservateur on nous dit
en mauricie les superbes rien faire par
exemple attache duel justement faire tu
as joué alors tour d'horizon sébastien
justement des endroits où ça pourrait
changer et prévoir des changements des
luttes à surveiller oui alors on vous a
parlé de l'est de montréal d'habitude
sans histoire rouge libéral le pq était
dans l'ès ici vous voyez que québec
solidaire a fait des gains au cours des
dernières années la coalition avenir
québec en a fait aussi ce que la caq
espère c'est que cette vague bleue
caquistes dans la montérégie va sauter
le fleuve saint-laurent et faire en
sorte que au centre de l'est de montréal
et puisse y avoir des députés de la
coalition avenir québec qui sont élus
laval très intéressant
voyez c'est rouge libéral ici christophe
ce kit de la coalition amiens québec
s'est fait élire dans sainte-rose toutes
les autres circonscriptions sont dans
le viseur de la coalition avenir québec
sauf peut-être chômé des très
intéressant chômé des anciennes
circonscriptions monsieur ouellette guy
ouellette qui était libéral élu libéral
mais qui est devenu indépendant par la
suite qu'ils aient gagné avec une forte
majorité les libéraux pensent qu'ils
sont capables de conserver cette
circonscription mais pour le reste
toutes les autres circonscriptions sont
dans le viseur de la coalition avenir
québec qui espère faire des gains sur
l'île ou à la la ça pour le parti
libéral du québec si ça s'avère bon
vérole
c'est une claque c'est une claque en
effet parce que vous avez vu la couleur
de la carte à la balle assez c'est
seulement du rouge libéral à part une
seule circonscription la montée
régissent les élections se gagnent
beaucoup dans 4 5 0 parce que il ya
beaucoup de circonscriptions alors
regardez la montérégie ces bleus
coalition avenir québec à part trois
circonscriptions il a encore mis en
garde parce que il ya une
circonscription qui s'appelle marie
victorin juste ici qui a été peinturées
en bleu cac à l'occasion d'une élection
partielle d'un match revanche la match
revanche de marie-victorin aussi en
effet et à surveiller donc deux
circonscriptions libérales aussi quand
on disait au début de l'émission que la
coalition avenir québec est en mode on
va chercher des circonscriptions
libérales ces deux circonscriptions
aussi ici c'est la circonscription de la
porte et la circonscription à la partie
si nicole ménard se représente pas
lapinière députée de la pinière guettant
barrette se représente pas non plus dont
power fait les deux ça fait donc la
grande région montréal il ya beaucoup de
circonscriptions c'est la machine à sous
des élections quand vous arrivez à
percer le temps et récolter des
circonscriptions vous avez des bonnes
chances de former le prochain
gouvernement et pour la caq qu'on a vu
hier il était minuit moins une mais
23h59 secondes lors de cette annonce
importante avec la ville de montréal
l'embauchent de 450 policiers
on a beaucoup dit depuis quatre à que la
cac n'avait pas beaucoup d'antennes à
montréal il y avait un oui madame
rouleau qui était la ministre
responsable mais qu' il y avait un
déficit montréal appelons ça comme seul
donc on veut prouver qu'on est capable
de faire son entrée sur l'île afin
d'accroître ça
ne fait pas de gains sur l'île de
montréal même s'il remporte le
gouvernement ça va être un échec pour
eux ils ont plusieurs circonscriptions
dans le viseur anjou loubriel sebastian
par les humoristes richer sociale sic
d'un à verdun saint henri sainte anne il
ya beaucoup de circonscriptions sur
l'île de montréal qui les lie la
correction n'est québec vise est l'un
des objectifs de françois legault
qui ne partagent pas publiquement mais
qui existe est de devenir un véritable
parti national et ça lui prend des
circonscriptions dans toutes les régions
sauf l'île de montréal ça lui prend plus
de circonscription à laval s'allumant
l'isu québec qui a seulement dominé par
le pq dont il a des objectifs est au
gouvernement c'est l'un des objectifs
l'autre objectif c'est d'étendre sa
présence d'être parti qui est vraiment
resté dans toutes les régions et c'est
pas encore le cas pour la coalition bois
québec long qui va avoir des luttes
intéressantes à suivre certainement d'où
cette logique d'expansion qui le killer
qui l'incarnent logique d'expansion à
l'éco raisons légales le quantitatif
c'est à dire on va chercher sherbrooke
et on va chercher jean pierre meyer le
qualitatif et le qualitatif pour que
monsieur legault par quinze jours
laissant derrière lui un parti qu'il ya
des assises solides c'est s'implanter
sur l'île de montréal et à laval pour
pour dire que son parti et paul le parti
des régions mais bien le parti du québec
et on parle d'aller chercher le vote
nationaliste n 1 du vote nationaliste à
montréal n'y a pas si longtemps vous
voyez du bleu foncé sur l'île on en boit
plus est ce que monsieur legault peut
prendre la chance de laisser québec
solidaire s'est installé plus fortement
sur l'île de montréal pas ce seuil en
plus c'est pas très bon pour son
gouvernement
cette impression comme montréal et dans
l'opposition c'est un phénomène qui
n'est pas davantage du québec qui est
pas davantage ce gouvernement du québec
ni de la coalition avenir québec oui on
peut pas gouverner sans avoir des yeux
des oreilles des antennes dans la
métropole ça c'est quand même le poumon
économique du québec oui le gouvernement
des régions au cercle ça a été ça a été
efficace dans son cas mais la prochaine
étape on la ville assez montréal
mémorial c'est la moitié de la
population du québec le faut toujours
bien qu'ils soient représentés à
l'assemblée nationale au gouvernement
actuellement il ya deux députés de la
coalition a bien québec sur l'île de
montréal mais c'est fort montérégie donc
on espère que ça va faire ça va faire
tache d'huile hamon ce qui est beaucoup
françois legault c'est sa force chez les
francophones et on l'oublié des
circonscriptions de montréal saint henri
sainte en deux circonscriptions
dominique anglade
4002 majorité la dernière fois elle est
en danger pour elle pourquoi parce que
les libéraux sont à moins de 10 % chez
les francophones ça reste une
circonscription où il y eu plus de 75 %
de francophones quand et à 10% 7% invite
pour sa sécurité en danger donc la force
chez les francophones la caq lui permet
de rêver dans des circonscriptions où l
époque l'on revient en 2008 on pensait
même pas de compétitif c'est aussi la
faiblesse du parti libéral parce que
pendant longtemps le parti libéral
presque toujours sauf à l'époque tête la
loi soit 178 l'affichage où il y avait
une partie égalité le parti libéral du
québec pouvait compter sur les
circonscriptions de l'ouest de l'île et
le vote anglophone et beaucoup à
l'iphone mais là il ya beaucoup
d'anglophones qui se sentent mal
représentée par le parti libéral et qui
se tissent de toute façon on n'est pas
en train de lire un gouvernement libéral
c'est parti c'est qu'ils naissent anglo
ils vont pas faire élire deux députés
selon - ce sera pas le parti égalité 2.0
mais il risque de faire mal à dominer
qu'enviable dans sa propre
circonscription parce qu'ils vont
envoyer des votes
à des endroits qui servent pas le parti
libéral mais qui vont avantages et
québec solidaire et la coalition restent
à la maison mais beaucoup beaucoup
qui vote en protestant en restant assis
à la maison et ça c'est très dangereux
au parti libéral vous ouvrez un élément
une parenthèse d'importantes les chefs
bon monsieur legault dans l'assomption
sera est un avion pendant qu'on voit des
images en direct de dominique anglade
qui est dans son autobus il descend de
son autobus ou qu'ils aient monde à ce
que c'était en accéléré
et pas tout à fait a dit république res
d'encourir ben on parlait d'elle c'est
un ris un talent il ya des défis pour
les chefs dans leur propre
circonscription cette année c'est facile
oui saint pierre et ses bureaux le monde
on l'a pas choisi facile en allant dans
l'essai construction de bourges et qui
va devenir camille laurens était une
circonscription péquiste rappelez-vous
de maka kotto qui avaient été élus pour
le parti québécois non plus dans cette
circonscription mais ce ne sera pas
facile monsieur campeau a gagné par pas
beaucoup de devoirs de votes aux
dernières élections donc on pense qu'il
ya quand même un fond péquiste dans
cette circonscription dominique anglade
contrairement aux autres élections ça va
ce sera difficile pour madame anglais
dès lors à une bataille à faire dans sa
circonscription je connais aussi vous
disiez alors marqué un des pc market
pour vous montrer la circonscription
alors on commence à être un peu plus
dans l'ouest 7
quand il est question de marquette
monsieur gabriel nadeau-dubois d'angoua
n'y a pas de problème il va être élu
facilement monsieur legault vous l'avez
dit aussi le parti conservateur éric
duhaime dans chauveau va avoir une
bataille à faire évidemment un à trois
pour qui ce n'est pas évident de se
retrouver ça et donc mais c'est
symptomatique de la leur de cette
campagne est elle aussi il ya trois
parties qui sont qui veulent avoir
augmenté leur nombre de députés là qu'à
québec solidaire un parti conservateur
évidemment il y en a deux les libéraux
et les péquistes qui essaient de sauver
les meubles littéralement de leur le
nombre de leurs comtés et ça illustre
donc le défi des chefs aussi dans l'eure
se construit il ya quatre des cinq chefs
qui en seront à leur premier débat donc
ça aussi c'est un facteur il ya un
renouveau ça illustre renouveau on a
quand même deux qui ont débattu avec
françois legault à l'assemblée nationale
par ce qui leur donne un avantage par
rapport aux deux autres cas brianna
doute bois du cndp récit d'histoires non
là aussi en gorille juste pour ramener
sur ce que c'est la csg sur les chefs
est la limite c'est presque une bonne
nouvelle pour un chiffre qui réussit à
sauver l'immeuble de couler avec le
navire parce que de toute façon et vol
ils vont marcher la planche
si ça finit mal pour le parti québécois
ou pour le parti libéral dominique
anglade st pierre plamondon mon pouvoir
régler sont encore plus facilement s'ils
sont pas élus que s'il se retrouve au
malheur
12.2 voté à l'assemblée nationale tant
qu'à couler le capitaine colle avec
lorsque vous dis ok on verra je rappelle
mesdames et messieurs qu'on attend
monsieur legault qui va aller
s'entretenir prendre un café c'est une
quinzaine de minutes habituellement avec
michel doyon le lieutenant gouverneur
pour lui demander de dissoudre
l'assemblée et sa part tout de suite
après le décret est pris
auparavant conseil des ministes
messieurs legault ne frappe pas j'allais
dire l'erreur tactique que mal à marois
avait fait la veillée dans une première
journée comme ça de ne pas faire pas
tenir de points 13 et ça a été le sujet
pendant une journée bin voila vous
voulez donner le ton à cette
déclenchement de la campagne actuelle
vous avez davantage parce que vous êtes
premier ministre donc c'est vous qui
décidez du moment où vous déclenchez en
effet en 2014 je sais pas qui a passé
assez au cabinet de madame marois mais
elle a juste fait une déclaration et la
peau prix de question donc on a parlé
que de la déclaration on aurait il faut
que le premier ministre répondait aux
questions pour le déclenchement des
élections la raison pour laquelle il
déclenche ce qu'il veut faire pendant la
campagne électorale je pense que madame
marois sa mort peut-être encore les
doigts parce qu'elle était en avance et
ce moment là d'un sondage des sondages
lui disait qu'elle était en avance a
vraiment joué sur le résultat final des
élections peut-être pas mais ça occupé
la 1re journée et quand vous êtes
premier ministre vous voulez
occuper de façon positive la première
journée de la campagne non évidemment
les gens vont se dire monsieur legault
intérêt à moins faire campagne que
d'autres chefs comme on a vu avec ford
en ontario est ce que vous croyez qu'il
va adopter cette stratégie la dette de
deux pattes ne pas faire d'annoncé trop
risqué de jouer non parce que monsieur
james lui reproché hier fessiers ou peu
remis de la jouer
plus plus prudes amara d'abord françois
legault n'a pas le tempérament de john
ford en ontario qui donnait naturel un
peu plus et heineken et les faire soit
le vaut donc je pense qu'il va faire une
vraie campagne par contre les mots qui
reviennent beaucoup à la taxe on voit
être raisonnable et responsable on est
au pouvoir et nous devra appliquer ce
qu'on promet contrairement à d'autres
partis politiques dont on voyage on a
quelques annonces intéressantes en
banque on veut occuper le terrain on
l'occupé même avant la campagne talent
de judée je fais des annonces électorale
du côté de la cac mais ne vous attendez
pas à des annonces aussi spectaculaire
que la caq des dernières années qui
avaient besoin d'attirer l'attention
qu'ils avaient besoin d'aller d'être
clivant sur certains sujets pour être
capable de monopoliser la discussion
ce n'est plus la même caquelon on a
gouverné au centre on veut rester au
centre où il va y avoir des baisses
d'impôts où on va parler du coût de la
vie de la santé mais une proposition
comme celle de 2018 le on voulait poser
des tests de français aux nouveaux
arrivants pions chicaner avec ottawa et
ça se fait soit il y en aura pas de ça
cela on voyait les deux marques à savoir
on avait passé à moins qu'ottawa décide
de participer au débat à la cua il soit
revenu québec on dit on sait où on se
situe sur le plein relations
fédérales-provinciales les gens savent
déjà notre rapport avec le gouvernement
trudeau n'a pas besoin d'en faire plus
on va parler quoi santé économique ou de
la vie un peu d'environnement et on
recommence santé économique ou de la vie
un petit peu d'environnement ça va être
beaucoup les thèmes qu'on m'aborde à la
caq relations fédérales-provinciales
identité très peu ont dit on le fait les
gains qu'on avait à faire de ce côté là
c'est de la gestion des risques en gros
la campagne de françois legault se le
dire des passages obligés qu'ils peuvent
pas disparaître et qui sont les plus
risqués et les débats des chefs c'est à
ce moment l'autre tu peux signer une
campagne électorale mais le débat des
chefs à 5
c'est impossible de prédire la dynamique
ou de se mettre à l'abri de tous et avec
mon participants de ce débat à ce débat
qui sont des banques aux munitions du
bon comme une cata de deux chaussures la
campagne de françois legault pipette
champ des bornes quand j'ai su me trompe
mais on porte beaucoup plus attention à
une campagne et alou québec provinciales
en ontario donc un chef peut pas se
permettre de prendre sa relaxe deuxième
chose je vous cite aux textes concis de
françois legault on mène peut-être 3 0
en troisième période mais on jouera pas
la trappe on se repliera pas sûr
chercher leur âge le sahel
ils savent comment me parler
mais exactement de pas il faut qu'ils
bougent mouvement
québec et de l'ontario vous avez raison
de souligner leur apport la petite
provinciale complètement différent c'est
l'inversé en ontario c'est est beaucoup
plus une campagne fédérale qu'on fait au
québec mais on parle elle de l'énergie
ou de fêtes avec avec vos mains et
ancien maire de tous les premiers
ministres sortants que j'ai couvert qui
se sont mis en pilote automatique parce
qu'il avait une bonne avance en campagne
électorale sur devenu chef d'un parti
d'opposition
c'est les électeurs s'attendent à ce
qu'on travaille pour son sa victoire et
ils veulent voir qu'on travaille pour
gagner
et ce serait la dernière chose à faire
que de s'asseoir sur ses gains on fera
pas de vagues dans ce temps là on se
retrouve
kate univers j'ai pas au grand large
très bien on a vu le calendrier
apparaître ont pu le revoir on va en
refaire ensemble donc l'histoire de ceux
des prochains 36 jours ben on est au
déclenchement le 28 on en a on s'est
permis de mettre notre émission qu'on
présente à radio-canada cinq chefs
l'élection le 4 c'est dimanche prochain
ça arrive très vite ça c'est une
vingtaine de minutes seul à seul en fait
céline galipeau anne marie dussault et
moi on interroge les chefs un après les
autres pendant une vingtaine de minutes
donc à peu près tous les sujets il pas
ce débat des chefs le nous le 22 il et
on aurait pu mettre l'autre débat aussi
apte à tva qui est
ils sont le 16 en tout cas bref 15h15
merci sébastien 15 là-bas 22 chez nous
et la soirée électorale évidemment le 3
donc ça va aller vite regardez ça veut
quand même dire qu'il ya deux semaines
avec les débats où les caravanes ne
roulent moins de se dire que les des
postes un exercice extrêmement
importants comme chantait le disait si
bien où on met beaucoup d'énergie à
préparer les débats donc comme une
campagne électorale un peu bizarre
pendant ces deux semaines les deux jours
avant on prépare les débats généralement
donc effectivement ça va être un peu
plus mollo ou 40 séries la vraie
campagne commence autour du 15
celle des bottes tpr et ça déboule après
sa 6ème tendance qui s'installe après le
généralement est difficile ça se fait là
on a vu des gens faire brian mulroney
libre-échange suis sorti perdant en
gagner une majorité mais ces pommes ce
qu'on veut en sortant des débats de se
retrouver avec une tendance inattendue
quand on est
gouvernement sortant très bien on
retrouve marie josée paquet comme aux
visites à montréal et vous avez parlé à
plusieurs électeurs ce matin par cette
journée magnifique alors qu'est ce qu'on
en dit
écoutez ce qu'on entend sur toutes les
lèvres c'est la question du logement du
prix des maisons donc de justice
intergénérationnelle parce que seulement
en 2022 là le regroupement des
associations de kata parle d'une
augmentation de 9 % des loyers alors
c'est énorme les gens n'ont n'en peuvent
plus ont de la misère à payer leur loyer
d'ailleurs il manque cruellement de
logements abordables de logements
sociaux on a eu plusieurs annonces à cet
effet d'ailleurs dans les dernières
semaines un autre enjeu important
patrice l'environnement et je vous donne
un exemple je suis présentement à verdun
et dans verdun et bien isabelle melançon
qui du parti libéral qui se représente
est bien on se rappelle qu' elle est
porte parole en environnement elle a été
ministre de l'environnement sous lé
gouvernement couillard et elle
affrontera québec solidaire donc la
candidate alejandro agag ménez qui est
une spécialiste de l'environnement elle
a un doctorat en développement durable
et du côté de la cac et bien on à
véronique tremblay qui est une
conseillère de ville de projet montréal
alors vous voyez un peu l'association
environnement entre eux cela donc ce
sera un enjeu incontournable de
l'arrondissement de la circonscription
plutôt de verdun un autre sujet
important la mobilité le transport
collectif mais aussi tous les projets du
mtq on parle du tunnel louis hippolyte
lafontaine qui sera fermée trois voies
sur 6 jusqu'en 2025 un casse tête pour
les automobilistes donc on veut un
meilleur arrimage des travaux on veut
savoir ce qui se passe avec ses travaux
il y a également le rem de l'est tout
n'est pas concluant le rem de l'ess qui
est revenu dans les mains du
gouvernement et de la ville de montréal
l'acceptabilité sociale n'est pas au
rendez-vous et surprenamment un patrice
et bien la sécurité n'a pas ressorti
lorsqu'on a parlé aux électeurs nous
étions plutôt dans l'ouest de la ville
peut-être que l'enjeu est plus criant
dans montréal est je vous laisse
entendre certains électeurs on voit que
les gens de la difficulté quand même
soit déménagée soir rencontrer leurs
besoins financiers
les besoins sont immenses illimité mais
doivent se loger je pense que c'est
devenu de plus en plus difficile je
dirais surtout sur l'île de montréal
peut-être améliorer les services
concernant
le recyclage
tout ce qui concerne l'environnement les
micros transports la micro ou la micro
mobilité je trouve que c'est intéressant
de d'améliorer les voies cyclables
trouve qu'en ce moment il ya beaucoup d'
inégalités socio-économiques c'est très
visible à verdun dans l'est de montréal
qu'est-ce-qui question de le système ne
s'en fait plus aussi l'environnement
beaucoup
donc l'enjeu pour l'île de montréal ce
sera de voir la percée de la caq au
détriment du parti libéral du québec
vous en parlez patrice avec vos
analystes c'est vraiment l'enjeu de
cette campagne est ce que le parti
libéral pourra garder des bastions comme
la circonscription dominique anglade
saint henri sainte anne verdun il y a
également anjou louis-riel alors cédé
des luttes que l'on devra observer merci
beaucoup je vous les ai montré en
accéléré on vous montre comment ça s'est
passé de nick anglade qui saute juste un
classique de début de campagne a fait
visiter sa son autobus de campagne
donc où on elle va passer la grande
majorité du temps lors des trente cinq
prochains jours alors ce sont des
bureaux volants roulant avec tous les
services et les journalistes
bien qu'ils soient moins nombreux
suivent dans un autre autobus derrière
alors effet
voilà c'est pas si vous en avez aussi
beaucoup connu
le bus que vous voyez avec les couleurs
de la chef la chef ou le chef et dans ce
but cela puis en arrière il ya un ou
deux autres quarts de plus avec les
journalistes dont les journalistes sont
pas tout à fait le même nom mais tout
avait elle même
lux entre guillemets que celui que vous
avez vu dominique anglade donc les
journalistes sont pas physiquement avec
le chef dans le même autocar ils suivent
un peu plus loin ce qui empêche pas les
moutons c'est en gros ce qui passait à
mâcher contrôle à portage ou des fois on
fait c'est ça le conseil en
communication va aller chercher des
journalistes dans le bus des
journalistes pour mettre les choses au
clair ou dit voici ce que ma chef ou mon
cher vous voulez dire ou encore à venir
s'asseoir tous ses jeunes années
cependant les conversations pour
éclairer
les esprits justin que tout le monde se
mette à bâiller des reportages etc
délicatement présenté dans un coffret
des râles à cause d avion passe beaucoup
plus de temps proximité des chefs parce
qu'elle n'y a pas deux ça vient mais
avoir des autobus sont un peu différent
ce une bonne idée parce que c'est pas
toujours le cas au fédéral et quand les
gens pensent que vous êtes dans
l'autobus d'un chef qui n'est pas
populaire ça peut être assez désagréable
oui j'ai choisi c'est pas lui
c'est fait alors voilà monsieur legault
qui arrive la journée
s'enclencher y aura ensuite je vous le
rappelle mesdames et messieurs 10h 11h
11h45 12h30 13h les pointes prêts
successifs des chaînes sur le bouquet on
va écouter
existait une
campagne qui commence cinq semaines avec
vous quel bonheur qui fait beau au
prince donc on est vraiment contents des
gros enjeux aux enjeux comme toutes les
campagnes
alors
alors voilà un très belle journée dit il
monsieur legault qui
comme ça tous les jours s'est passé puis
vous avez dit tout à l'heure un tout
début d'émission son adversaire s'est
lui même il peut par son tempérament des
fois très patient est un peu alors il là
il veut montrer le françois legault
jovial de bonne humeur serein et qui va
marcher dans cette campagne les grands
ouais celui qui connecte avec les
québécois parce qu'il faut le dire
monsieur legault a réussi à connecter
avec nikos pas pour rien que il est
aussi étonnant ils sont là je pense
qu'il ya deux dangers qui guettent
françois lebon dans cette campagne
électorale françois legault lui même
parfois il se met les pieds dans les
plats donc et ses conseillers en
communication en sont totalement
conscient donc éviter les gaffes le plus
possible mais rester naturel quand même
l'autre danger c'est le taux de
participation est ce que les gens vont
se dire ah ben il va tellement passé
comme une balle qu'on n'ira pas voter et
donc il se pourrait avoir un effet sur
le vote pour la coalition revenu québec
ou à l inverse les gens vont se dire
mais ils passent tellement fort que je
veux contrebalancer je vais avoir un
contrepoids démocratique donc je vais
voter pour un parti d'opposition pour
lui envoyer un message c'est pas carte
blanche c'est pas un chèque en blanc
qu'on donne pour ton prochain monde et
ça dans certaines des circonscriptions
dont on a parlé ça pourrait jouer à
l'admettre j'en dis est tellement au
temps tombent d'avoir une opposition
plus solides puis bon ben je peux voter
pq je peux voter qu elle peut voter
libéral le le le l'enjeu pour monsieur
le fait que l'opposition soit morcelé
saen françois legault parce que un des
secrets de son succès en ce moment c'est
que devant lui l'opposition se divise le
vote d'opposition jugent d'ailleurs
françois legault parle toujours des
oppositions une personnalise plus le
débat à un certain moment là qu'un
comparse actuelle salle s imposer comme
étant l'adversaire naturel souvenez-vous
de la city ryan sur les waka l'assemblée
nationale maurice duplessis tour on
voyait que tu es monté on s'est dit bon
on voit les définir et ça on s'est rendu
compte avec le temps que tu es ne monte
trop et que la division devrait presque
parfaite entre les partis d'opposition
servait le gouvernement alors
attendez-vous pas moins de controverses
très particulière à ce qu'on parle de la
partie on veut dire les oppositions en
les mettant dans le même panique ça joue
en faveur de françois bigot et avant
d'être une exception pour le parti
conservateur du québec si la caq
s'aperçoit que tu aimes est entrain de
grury plus sérieusement dans des bottes
caquistes le monsieur legault va
peut-être se sentir plus un tc
personnaliser le débat dans ce sens là
surtout que si quelqu'un fait vraiment
procès juste des mesures sanitaires ce
sera pas dominique anglade ou paul st
pierre plamondon et sur ce terrain je
n'ai pas l'impression mois que françois
legault veut se laisser manger tout rond
cela dit sur la participation la partie
plus la participation est élevée
normalement plus les résultats sont
série donc on peut pas écrire sur un
bulletin de vote je veux une position
forte mais et une faible participation
généralement ça aide le gouvernement
sortant se faire réélire ça a été le cas
en ontario ou
non et ce sont les vagues et le
changement qui ont tendance à faire
augmenter le taux de participation en
personne cliente avantage lefrançois de
goût c'est probablement l'endroit où il
est dans le cycle politique c'est à dire
un seul mandat les électeurs sont pas
encore où on peut encore vraiment
commencé à être fatigués de bois ce
qu'il a produit oui mais ça se produit
de toute façon regardez justin trudeau
au premier mandat deuxième à chaque
mandat il ya plus de fatigue à l'égard
du gouvernement en place et le
gouvernement est plus fatigué ça va
enfin le temps qui érode toute
participation c'est important de le
noter 2018 il était plus bas à
66,4 2014 60 et en 2012 74 alors est-ce
qu'il va remonter en haut de la barre
des 70 à voir ce sera sur 2012 74 francs
chars et les printemps arabes un
changement de gouvernement oui
effectivement risque est beaucoup
françois legault actuellement c'est chez
les 55 ans et plus qui votent en plus
grand nombre que chez les jeunes il est
dans une avance écrasante
alors même si le taux de participation
et bosses et les 55 ans et plus vont
voter il est temps et les dents voiture
comme régis labeaume manon cyr luc
ferrandez que je retrouve encore une
fois est-ce que les gens vont aller
voter parce que le danger c'est dira il
ya tellement en avance esker vous senti
que ça va lever parce que moi je vous ai
déniché un malade mental de politique
mais je trouve que cette campagne est
fort intéressante on gardera
configuration politique du québec
d'abord le beaucoup dit
dans quelle mesure les partis
d'opposition vont pouvoir garder leurs
acquis d'un code tuer ce faire des gains
les libéraux qu'est ce qui va se passer
d'un région de montréal bref région
parce que les gens pour s'intéresser
d'après vous ce une campagne qui va
quand même
relevé des surprises même vous ont
peut-être un but je pense que ça ne
lisait télé sera pas tellement les gens
sont fatigués les enlever la saison
l'ag fans belges d'envoi vous enlever au
calaisis non mais écoutez des astros
fatigué j'avais les tirs ils étaient
inégaux eaton vance terriblement l'oeil
à une avalanche de promesses ils ne
croiront plus personne à part le fait
que monsieur legault veut la renvoyer
chez eux très bientôt alors moi je
prédis où je pense personnellement que
le taux de participation sont encore
plus beau que la dernière fois donc
maintenant on est tous d'accord un
mercenaire suffisait pas que non non non
non mais moi je te dise tout d'accord
avec régis ça va commencer les espoirs
ça fait des souvenirs mais dans le fond
mais moi je pense qu'au contraire avec
cinq machines famille on au 5e parti et
moi je pense que des enjeux dans la
région attenton j'entendais parler des
électeurs de montréal vous savez quand
on parle d'un logement le problème de
logement à montréal c'est une image bien
en région il ya des enjeux et je pense
que les gens - ce ne sont peut-être pas
là cette semaine parce que l'école
comment ça on en voit les jeunes à
l'école attendez que la fin du travail
parle vous allez voir les gens vont être
encore plus immoral et peut-être qu'on
dit souvent que la campagne est long
mais le fait qu'elle soit sur 28 de bien
nouveau outre un travail de jour je
pense que ça lui ferait que les gens
mais moi je prédis au contraire que les
gens vont aller voter parce que les
machines vont faire sauter le pas et
partout au québec et ça ce sera suivi je
pense ok le tu es ou là sur votre niveau
de d'attentes face à cette campagne
entre les deux je pense que lorsque les
gens de nos positions varient peu
intelligent pour le parti conservateur
du québec notamment mais sans volant une
colère le fait de ne pas avoir été pris
en compte dans le plus prestigieux
le savon sur la crise sanitaire je pense
que les gens du parti québécois et du
parti libéral vont aller voter parce que
les deux parties font rire en panne
d'idée on le lui avec la pass transport
du parti québécois
on l'a vu avec délégation du parti la
sécurité et des risques
montréal et je pense que déjà tué celle
d'aller voter parce que
québec solidaire propose un changement
d'ère et ça ne se sait pas ce qu'il dit
c'est que ce n'est pas la cas
les problèmes en profondeur la crise il
faut avoir une vision à long terme la
crise comme une crise entre mènent
ensemble de problèmes à résoudre dans la
journée et donc je pense qu'un ancien
robotique ou des gens qui va concussion
ok il ya des espoirs merci merci à vous
trois on revient dans l'est du québec
parce que bon région de montréal
nouveautés s'arrêterait à surveiller
l'est du québec où si on vienne parler
du pq lui que vient de dire les gens du
pq vont aller voter je le souhaite en
tout cas les députés présents le
souhaitent et les nouveaux candidats je
vous ai je vous le dis tout de suite les
du québec ce sera ma région chouchou
pendant les accalmies patienter parce
que ça pourrait être dramatique en fait
vous voyez l'est du québec c'est ben le
parti québécois a pu lire cette
circonscription dans l'est du québec qui
appartient au parti québécois matane
matapédia on va le surveiller évidemment
mais pascal bérubé va se faire élire il
ya à peu près aucun doute là dessus mais
toutes les autres sont en jeu rimouski
vous allez avoir beaucoup de visites à
rimouski parce que les chèvres ont
tourné à rimouski je vous signale québec
solidaire à lamanon mobile et la mano
mobile c'est une camionnette de manom
ans et il ya le tocard du chef mais chef
pour l'élection gabriel nadeau dubois et
il ya la manon mobile qui va se promener
dans les villes universitaires
rimouski ville universitaire donc à
surveiller gaspé mais jan perry melanson
rappelez vous il y avait un des
comptages aux dernières élections
serrées a passé avec moins de 50 voit
donc la coalition bois québec a dit
viser là dessus bonaventure ces
constructions intéressante
péquiste aussi alexis deschênes anciens
l'autre enjeu collet oui voilà c'est ça
qui a perçu longuet kenzy qui est passé
par le droit avant de se lancer en
politique et dans cette circonscription
la le pq espère beaucoup pouvoir la
conserver sur la côte nord il ya une
serre parce qu'une fois qu'on va
surveiller duplessis lorraine richard
avait passé sauf erreur avec moins de
cent voix aux dernières élections aussi
donc c'était très serré dans ces
circonscriptions et les
îles-de-la-madeleine aussi où ça a été
extrêmement serrée aux dernières
élections justes ici les îles de la
madeleine donc bataille des mères aux
îles de la madeleine monsieur la pierre
le maire actuel vizille contre joël
arsenault ancien maire des îles donc ça
pourrait très important pour d'higuain
pour la coalition and ear québec ou pour
québec solidaire est très important
évidemment pour le parti québécois avec
des pertes possibles mais aussi
peut-être conservé certaines
circonscriptions et quand on revient
pour parlera à philippe j'ai fourni dans
quelques minutes quand revient aux
sondages quand on voit la vence cantons
où c'est par le vote francophone
l'avant cela cac est encore plus
importante alors damas et le vote
francophone silvia sur denis vous êtes à
denis leduc à rimouski justement l'avez
entendu sébastien vous jette sa région
chouchou
alors on voit l'enjeu de fond là qui
sous-tend tous les débats c'est l'avenir
du parti québécois comme l'expliqué
sébastien alors celui sur les ans une
terre à terre c'est comme partout
ailleurs au québec c'est le
développement économique c'est la crise
du logement qui frappe particulièrement
fort à gaspé et il sait rimouski
rimouski c'est 0,2 pour cent le taux
d'inoccupation c'est l'un des pires au
québec on est beaucoup pour équiper par
des questions de la situation des
personnes âgées parce que nous région
sont un petit peu plus vieille donc sans
impact sur le réseau de la santé
l'environnement qui toujours une
préoccupation ici mais au-delà de tout
ça c'est l'avenir du parti québécois
parce que comme le disait sébastien
l'est du québec là bas saint laurent
gaspésie visé côte-nord c9 compter et à
la dernière élection sept de ses comptes
et ont été remportées par le parti
québécois lorient font nationaliste un
fonds souverainiste très importants dans
plusieurs parties de ces régions de
bassin en gaspésie et la côte-nord mais
à la dernière élection commune dit
également sébastien les majorités du
parti québécois ont été quelquefois très
fortes doses il s'était simplement 15
voix de majorité et ce sera une bataille
des des maires comme comme vous disiez
parce que la caq a recruté le maire
actuel comme candidat monsieur jeunes
enfants la pierre à gaspé c'est
particulier la majorité de pégas demi
rue melançon c'était 40 et une voix
seulement obtenu à la suite d'un
décompte à un recomptage judiciaire et
c'était l'adversaire c'était parti
libéral et cette fois ci la situation
politique change énormément le parti
libéral n'a pas encore identifié son
camp dieter d'en gaspiller donc c'est
très significatif là sur la force
politique du parti libéral donc dans
gaspille pas arriver à peu près
n'importe quoi comme le disait sébastien
rimouski ce sera une bataille de tous
les instants parce que le parti
québécois espère conserver ce comté
qu'il détient depuis fort longtemps la
caq espère faire une percée et puis et
québec solidaire également alors il y
aura des batailles importantes
hier j'ai des collègues qui ont tendu le
micro à gaspé et est rimouski pour
demander aux gens quels sont vos trucs
tuation vous allez voir ses patients
typique du tout mais des préoccupations
très ras terre on peut écouter ses
citoyens tout ce qui regarde l'économie
c'est très important la santé bien
évidemment
vraiment dans la continuité des choses
j'espère sincèrement le qu'on va pouvoir
passer à autre chose par rapport à la
pandémie j'en n'ai pas d'attentes je
crois pas tellement les attentes les
premières je comprends pas son attitude
du tout le réchauffement climatique là
c'est un gros des bols ça serait
important de régler ça le climat tient
ce sera encore mieux que ce que plus de
toutes les choses qui se posent à
camille petit simpson pense que la clis
arrêter les conditions des éducatrices
autant milieux familiaux car cpr poct
l'éducatrice pas classe nous on est des
nouvelles quand on habite à gaspé depuis
1er juillet je pense qu'un nos plus gros
défi ça a été trouvé un logement je veux
qu'au provincial ni ou fédéral votre jeu
somistes
je crois pas au pouvoir provincial et
fédéral dans un pays cologna
et patrice un petit mot sur la côte-nord
sauver ces péquiste depuis très
longtemps c'est il le comté de duplessis
c'est à dix villes une députée du parti
québécois depuis 1976 sauf qu'à la
dernière élection lorraine richard avait
obtenu une simple majorité de 127 voix
la caq a recruté une candidate
autochtone alors ça ça pour avoir un
impact important et dans l'autre compter
de la côte-nord baie comeau qc le conti
de rené lévesque l'hydroélectricité la
caq a recruté le maire actuel le mien
montigny et ça ça promet une bataille
importante pour ce continent il pourrait
y avoir des changements il y aurait des
batailles assurément ce sera vraiment
surveiller on est content de savoir
qu'on est le chouchou de sébastien mais
effectivement il y aura beaucoup
beaucoup de batailles ici est le
portrait de fond l'or ce qui sous tend
tout ça c'est l'avenir du parti
québécois mais tout à fait ou 7 le
chouchou de des péquistes ou si je vais
l'enjeu pour eux est ici on espère leur
que les le fond péquiste là se
mobilisent pour sauver ce parti c'est ça
que c'est ce que les stratèges péquiste
espère et à l'occasion on entend des
gens nous dire bah ce parti-là a été
tellement important dans l'histoire du
québec qu'il ne mérite pas de mourir
alors on verra le choix des électeurs
très bien fort intéressant merci
beaucoup fait les bougies fourni à qui
on parlera tout au long de cette
campagne
québec 125 collaborateurs politiques
bonjour fait l'objet bonjour patrie
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver ben
tout à fait un petit mot on va aller
dans les courbes macro pour tout le
québec mais je veux quand même vous
entendre sur l'est du québec c'est
extrêmement important pis il faut faire
attention jacques 0 oui mais je le
disais tout à l'heure le vote
francophone la cac et très en avant mais
pas des mouvements des sous mouvement
des gens qui disent oui attention veux
pas qu'il meure donc plus donc ils
valoir une dynamique régionale
définitivement les mouvements
hyperlocaux sont plus difficiles à
déceler dans les sondages cependant
généralement le québec fonctionne en
vague lorsqu'on voit des grands
mouvements au niveau national ça suit
dans les circonscriptions il ya des
exceptions bien sûr mais c'est justement
ce sont des exceptions et les le code de
rimouski était une exception en 2018
c'était les circonscriptions le pq avait
augmenté son vote sur niveau national il
était passé de 33 % à 25 % bon alors
montrez nous d'abord les intentions de
vote mais on va regarder les courbes
dans le temps c'est ça qui est important
je crois même si on petit vous allez
nous lisent explique depuis le début de
l'année vous voyez les intentions de
vote ont été généralement stables vous
avez ici des sondages l'est ce sont les
points et les courbes ce sont les
projections du vote donc extrêmement
instable et en fait on peut reculer
jusqu'à 2018 peut voir beaucoup de
mouvement sauf une certaine un certain
petit boost pour la caq au début de la
pandémie et patrice c'est important de
mentionner c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire moderne du québec où nous
avons des sondages réguliers ou un parti
au pouvoir même dans tous les sondages
pendant une période de quatre ans yapo
lui un sondage une firme professionnelle
qui a montré un autre parti en avance et
ça ce n'est jamais arrivé une telle
domination pendant aussi longtemps donc
vous voyez les partis d'opposition ici
qui se bataille entre 10 et 20% chacun
le parti libéral est toujours deuxième
mais en train de se faire rattraper
graduellement par le parti conservateur
et et québec solidaire et si on regarde
l'état actuel des choses à la ligne de
départ bien sûr ce n'est pas une
prédiction du résultat de votre bien sûr
ce sont la ligne de départ voici ce que
ça donne les projections basées sur une
multitude de sondage vous voyez la cac
qui est à 42 % loin devant ses rivaux 25
points devant le parti libéral en
deuxième place québec solidaire qui
peuvent conservateur et qui ferme la
marche le parti québécois on voit ici 9%
rappelons en 2018 le parti québécois a
eu 17 pour cent du vote donc c'est
presque la moitié ici alors évidemment
si le pq reste autour de 9 ou 10 % dans
les intentions de votes extrêmement
difficile de voir le pq garder la
majorité de ses acquis ça voudrait dire
quoi et là je mets toutes les pincettes
est
nécessaire ça voudrait dire quoi un
pourcentage comme celui là sur le nombre
de sièges que l'a4 pourrait obtenir et
les autres partis je partage votre
réserve là-dessus patrice bien sûr les
projections de sièges sont des estimés
avec des ciels d'aider des chiffres
régionaux bien sûr mais lorsqu'on
considère le découpage démographique le
découpage régional et le fait aussi que
la caq même par 35 points auprès des
francophones c'est une avance immense et
donc vous ce que ça donne à la ligne de
départ encore une fois j'ai une estime
et de 99 sièges pour la coalition avenir
québec entre bracket ici vous avez
l'intervalle de confiance donc le pire
des scénarios actuels seraient 82 sièges
le meilleur serait 106 pour la collusion
venir québec le parti libéral a dit ses
sièges évidemment les l'ouest de
montréal le nord de montréal peut-être
une circonscription en outaouais
peut-être une à laval vous avez québec
solidaire qui t'a u18 compter en moyenne
évidemment c'est un peu sous son niveau
de 10 de 2018 mais quand même québec
solidaire s'est maintenu à peu près au
même niveau dans les intentions de vote
et finalement on voit ici le parti
québécois projeté favori dans une seule
circonscription c'est matane matapédia
mais un intervalle de confiance qui
s'étend jusqu'à 6 donc quelques points
de plus pour le parti québécois des
courses locale en particulier dans l'est
du québec dans le bas saint laurent
gaspésie et le pq pourrait reprendre ses
sièges là et finalement on ne le parti
conservateur pour l'instant pour
l'instant un projet a projeté à zéro
siège mais un intervalle de confiance
qui va de zéro jusqu'à 4 alors
évidemment ces chiffres lors vont
changer assurément au cours de la
campagne on va les mettre à jour à
chaque fois nous avons des nouvelles
données après la partager vous dites
philips intéressant fallait que je vous
dit ces chefs vont changer règle
générale et on l'a vu lors des trois
dernières campagnes au québec les
chiffres bouge en effet les chiffres
bouche à peine plus est pour un moins 5
pour l'autre +3 c'est très rare que ça
reste prix d'angelo commandes absolument
les dernières élections au québec qui a
terminé où elle avait commencé je pense
qu'on peut regarder 2008 ça fait quand
même 14 ans mais comme vous le dites
patrice ce sont les exceptions un peu la
même chose au fédéral soudainement la
campagne commence les électeurs portent
plus d'attention rire à ce que disent
les politiciens et les chiffres vont
bouger et surtout les québécois n'aiment
pas généralement mettre tous leurs oeufs
dans le même panier et donc il sait
c'est possible que 1 des partis
d'opposition plus arriver à récolter
plus d'appuis à consolider les appuis
anti cac de son côté est donc assurément
ses cheveux love ont progressé au cours
de la campagne bonne chose
gabriel nadeau dubois
on l'a vu dans le sondage du journal de
montréal hier
léger il est vraiment puis on le voit
quand on pose la question aux gens qui
se ferait le meilleur chef de
l'opposition il arrive à 30% mais son
parti plafonne donc il est beaucoup plus
populaire que son parti nadeau-dubois
exactement plus populaire que son parti
et donc ça indique que le plafond de
québec solidaire est peut-être un peu
plus élevé le problème vous voyez ici le
14 sièges pour espérer gagner des sièges
au québec solidaire il faut réussir à
battre la cac et rkc 35 points d'avance
auprès des francophones fait que même si
québec solidaire un manque son score
dans cette élection aussi il pourrait
quand même frappé un mur et
collectionner les deuxièmes places un
peu le même phénomène que éric duhaime
dans la région de québec il pourrait
avoir 15 16 % du vote et ne faire élire
aucun député parce qu'ils veulent
collectionner les deuxièmes places dans
les couronnes de québec et dans
chaudière-appalaches merci effet les
bougies on va se reparler merci très
clair très claire boucau pas triste
merci alors oui et ça bouge les sabots
juste un petit tour de table là dessus
pour dire une évidence mais qu'il faut
rappeler en début de campagne les
campagnes contrebasse et we be here yens
évidemment à la ligne de départ on prend
un polar oeil de la ligne de départ et
monsieur legault est nettement en avance
mais pendant une campagne électorale
tout peut arriver monsieur le groupe
trébucher ses adversaires peuvent
mobiliser le vote
contre la collusion avec le problème des
oppositions c'est qu'à quatre positions
ils sont morcelées et ça permet dans
certaines circonscriptions de faire
passer la coalition amiens québec parce
que il ya vote pour les oppositions
petites notes historiques à 99 sièges de
projection théorique on se rapproche des
102 de robert bourassa mais sur 110 en
1973 l'histoire nous apprend qu'en 76
300 plus tard malgré cette très forte
majorité monsieur bourassa avait perdu
les élections contre le parti québécois
76 l'arrivée de rené lévesque un petit
mot là dessus sur l'importance des
campagnes que ça peut faire bouger
malgré tout on a parlé du fait que ça
bouge est en campagne au québec plus
souvent qu'autrement depuis 15 ans c'est
vrai aussi au fédéral d'ailleurs en
portion fédérale les p ô surprise des
élections fédérales le dernier cycle les
cinq ou six dernières c'est toujours de
québec en 2011 on savait que les
québécois étaient fatigués de
stephen harper tout le monde pense
écrire qui s'élève sur pied sur le chef
d'opposition libéraux ça a donné la
bague orange le jour du déclenchement il
ya personne qui voyait jack layton
prendre tous les sièges qui a pris au
québec en 2015 même fatigue tout le
monde se dit ça va être mon coeur
surtout au québec les libéraux fédéraux
vont nulle part un gars qui s'appelle
trudeau bon le gars qui s'appelle et et
obtenu un gouvernement majoritaire tout
ça ça se passe pendant une campagne et
en particulier au québec c'est l'endroit
où quand on dit les soldats vont aller
voter les péquistes sont allés voter
dans les faits et il ya beaucoup de gens
qui n'ont pas d'appartenance politique
comme ça et qui vont décider en campagne
où ils vont logis le 3 octobre suivant
gothique où il ya encore beaucoup de
10,6 avec well autour de 38% après les
sondages qui peuvent encore changer
d'idée la question c'est ce qu'ils vont
se mobiliser derrière un seul parti ou
non tant que l'opposition est fragmenté
salle avantage de françois legault y
quand même 40 2 44 % des gens qui
veulent voter pour françois legault sans
les 56% qui veulent pas de françois
legault la difficulté c'est qu'il dit
est logiquement les partis d'opposition
ne se ressemblent pas vous avez parti
conservateur et québec solidaire ce
n'est pas des vases communicants même si
on dit faudrait qu'un parti d'opposition
fédère opposition à la cac vous êtes
québec solidaire vous n'allez pas les
parts et la route à la cac en votant
pour le parti conservateur jamais de la
vie et l'inversé pas vrai est également
vrai il ya quelques exceptions des gens
qui sont anti système mais
majoritairement les gens idéologiquement
ne sont pas là peut-être encore plus
qu'au fédéral où les dirigeants sont
dits fédéral c'est loin c'est pas près
des gens et une grosse différence entre
votre cul et c'est parti conservateur
pour les services aux citoyens ici et
c'est ce qui va être peut-être à
surveiller encore que les exemples que
chantal données sont tout à fait
pertinents on avait un fatigue dans le
cycle électoral dont parlait sébacées
qui est moins présente maintenant ça dit
que quand on a un taux de satisfaction à
presque 60 pour ça gb déjà qu'ils vont
peut-être pas allés voter avec la colère
entre les dents et donc à ce moment là
la sellette la vie du parti sortant et
une bonne nuance parce qu'on peut ne pas
être satisfaits des services en santé
les gens le disent dans les sondages
réseau il a été en deçà des attentes ils
disent les sondages mais de manière
générale le taux de satisfaction lawyer
voyant jaune sur la satisfaction dans
chacun des domaines c'est sur le coût de
la vie est quand même 5 47% des
québécois qu'ils espèrent sur le goût
n'a pas été à la hauteur des attentes
sur le coût de la vie et ça va être un
thème de campagne important visiblement
le chèque n'était pas suffisant on
s'attend c'était des propositions pour
tamiser l'inflation nous aider à joindre
les deux bouts ça peut être le logement
ça peut être mais il faut que faudra que
des positions sur des sur le coût de la
vie parce que ça c'est un endroit où la
coalition bois québec ne se démarquent
peut-être pas par rapport à d'autres
alors que la pandémie la santé les
agissements y affronter une pandémie
stricte une chose même son impôt comme
bref un lieu qui secoue la ville il va y
avoir des propositions
différents participants est intéressant
et le lys opposition ont pas marqué
beaucoup de points contre françois
legault en quatre ans mais sur un coût
de la vie carlos leitao c'était du parti
libéral s'était levé en chambre un bon
modèle pour parler d'inflation à venir
françois legault lui avait produit
quelque chose du genre mais sur quelle
planète habitée vous et pourtant c'est
avéré c'est comme si les géants
publicité choc est prêtre auxiliaire qui
était parti un peu
mais quand même il ya un avantage je
sais que son ministre des finances est
bien construit christian dubé est
totalement respectée c'est une chose de
dire il nous donne pas les solutions
c'en est une autre de regarder les
autres équipes et monsieur legault jeu
très présent pas joué tellement l'équipe
mais en campagne électorale il ya
suffisamment de matériel pour jouer
l'équipe pas mal plus fort que ce qui a
fait jusqu'à présent notre île à ça
c'est clair réussi à répondre à un
besoin que les québécois avaient de
mettre de côté un débat entre le oui et
le non il a réussi à rassembler les
nationalisant 10 ans ne voit pas on ne
veut pas affronter cette question
déchirant de la souveraineté on veut la
mettre de côté peut on va assumer comme
nationale on a beaucoup ri du fait que
le mot nationaliste est devenu presque
un slogan mais il reste que les ja il ya
une adéquation entre ce que les
francophones au québec ont envie
d'entendre est ce qu'il dit ça c'est sa
grande réussite d'avoir réussi des deux
vieux partis en arrache ses propos rien
il y avait des nationalités national
chez les libéraux il ya des
nationalistes chez les péquistes mais
comme réussi à aller piger un peu dans
les deux surtout au parti québécois mais
sait on joue sur un peu sur l'émotion
ici le nationalisme la défense de
l'identité des valeurs pour ce qui est
de la chair des programmes de régler les
problèmes de réseau de la santé de crise
du logement et tout ça est comme un peu
d'attentes
insatisfaite face au gouvernement on va
le voir d'ailleurs alexandre duval vous
êtes là avec lui on va le voir sortir de
cette petite discussion avec
le lieutenant gouverneur où il a demandé
la dissolution de l'assemblée
législative de la donc du salon bleu les
députés sont revenus je le disais au
tout début des candidats les ministres
bien sûr reste ministres le premier
ministre s premier mini jeux le dit hier
par exemple sur le décès de faire
l'annoncé en catastrophe avant la
campagne c'est qu'on évite en campagne
électorale de faire des annonces
gouvernementales à moins d'une crise
bien sûr alors on l'a fait 23h59 7 cette
annonce avec la ville de montréal pour
les embauches de 450 policiers alors
quoi sa femme jeune alexandre de minutes
qu'il est là monsieur legault
oui mais écoutez il est pas encore avec
le lieutenant bernard wis au moment où
on se parle il est dans l'édifice honoré
mercier où il est arrivé un petit peu
avant 9h pour son conseil des ministres
virtuel donc pour l'adoption des décrets
qui vont officialiser le déclenchement
des élections et là on attend d'une
minute à l'autre qu'il sorte de
l'édifice honoré mercier pour faire la
petite marche vers le bureau du
lieutenant-gouverneur bon avec sa
conjointe et ça c'est prévu à 9h30 à
l'horaire alors on présume que le
conseil des ministres est toujours en
cours sur le point de se terminer parce
qu'il ne reste que quelques minutes
avant la rencontre prévenu prévue avec
le lieutenant-gouverneur à 9h30 ce qu'il
faut dire patrice c'est que lorsqu'il
est arrivé monsieur legault il est
arrivé tout sourire l'inversé aurait été
surprenant me direz-vous dans les
circonstances oui il n'a pas dit grand
chose comme le veut la tradition
mais il a tout de même dit que cette
campagne sera sera l'occasion de
débattre de gros enjeux et qu'est ce
qu'on entend par gros enjeu mais ce
qu'on sait c'est que dans la première
semaine de campagne électorale
monsieur legault devrait beaucoup parler
d'économie d'inflation de coût de la vie
donc ça ça fait partie des choses qui
feront l'objet des annonces au cours des
prochains jours pad annonce prévue
aujourd'hui par contre c'est important
de le dire aujourd'hui ce que la caq
souhaite faire c'est une démonstration
de force c'est la raison pour laquelle
on se rendra au saguenay en fin de
journée pour faire un grand
rassemblement militant parce que la caq
veut balayer le saguenay complètement
cette année pour l'instant il ne lui
manque qu'une circonscription dans cette
région là et c'est la circonscription de
jonquière détenu par le péquiste sylvain
gaudreault qui est très populaire dans
la région et monsieur boudreau ne se
représente pas alors la caq a de bonnes
raisons de croire que cette année elle
pourrait faire un balayage de la région
du saguenay et il n'y a pas que il n'ya
pas qu'au saguenay entre monsieur
legault espère faire des gains il le dit
à plusieurs reprises dans les derniers
mois qu'il voulait une majorité forte au
terme de cette élection et ça ça
implique qu'on fera des arrêts pas
seulement dans les châteaux forts khakis
mais aussi dans les circonscriptions où
la caq espère faire dès qu'un le serait
pas le premier à vous le dire
aujourd'hui
oui la caq espère faire des gays mais en
coulisses il ya tout de même une
certaine prudence et la voyez vous on me
dit monsieur legault est sur le point de
sortir du conseil des ministres on va
l'attendre mais j'ai une certaine
prudence on ne tient pas pour acquis que
la caq va faire des gains partout on ne
tient pas pour acquis que ce sera une
victoire non plus monsieur legault a
déjà fait des gaffes dans le passé
monsieur legault à quatre ans de bilan à
défendre cette fois ci le voici celle et
c'est terminé il est avec sa conjointe
isabelle aubret oui il avait vrai qui
est toujours très près lors des
campagnes électorales des traits points
mais elle est souvent sur le bord de
l'autobus et il nous saoulent go à la
blague ça ma console hier
monument
nouvion
vous avez dit au ministre pour justifier
le déclenchement de l'élection pull
en une élections à date fixe
donc pour beaucoup de choix mais ce que
je les leur indice de bien prendre pour
acquis et dans les voleurs de lecteurs
la confiance ça se mérite à chaque jour
donc faut rien prendre pour acquis que
cette campagne monsieur leubou sans
circonscription
105,60 pour
un gouvernement majoritaire ce choix
mais je prends rien pour acquis
comptez vous voulez perdre celle qu'on
n'avait plus que trois comtés réforma
je n'en vois les plus faciles
majoritaire
et
l'oma
bonjour monsieur provençal commente à
niveau
[Musique]
mais c'est quoi
définir le genre et sociétés groupe
hérité des quatre chemins
il reste tout d'abord pour vous monsieur
le lieutenant gouverneur jérômienne
6 ab oui
c'est un grand jour la démocratie
de milhas exprimer la parole est aux
peuples et dans la multiplicité des
joies effectivement
les est du nigeria
pour deux jours
l'assemblée
nationale trois
semaines
[Rires]
l'environnement la part des oubliés de
52 ans matin
alors vous avez constaté mesdames et
messieurs d'abord oui le son c'est parce
qu'à l'intérieur les murs sont solides
dans ses bureaux donc le son passé mais
on a compris l'essentiel avec humilité
dit il il faut prendre cette campagne
électorale gagner la confiance des
électeurs un grand jour pour la
démocratie pure journaliste lui a dit
non le lieutenant gouverneur lui a dit
michel doyon lieu d'hier et il ya une
offre multiple du oui sont plusieurs à
ryad a fait c'est parfait il y en a
plusieurs choix ce qui divise bien sûr
les votes d'opposition qu'on l'entend dû
dire l'environnement on va en parler la
santé coût de la vie et ça c'est des
évidences mais il dit ce qu'il avait dit
au jour 1 ou discours
inaugural
sébastien québec en disant je répète à
mes députés en amy ne faut rien prendre
pour acquis ça se gagne ma confiance est
toujours et on lui a précisé mme a
reproché à plusieurs reprises d'avoir
failli là-dessus d'avoir été trop
arrogant d'avoir été trop confiants de
ne pas écouter les gens qui n'étaient
pas d'accord avec lui essentiellement et
de dire vous êtes avec moi ou ça en
moins seule fo qui ils doivent se parler
j'imagine ils doivent se parler il va se
faire parler par ses conseillers en
communication aussi qui vont lui
rappeler de faire attention là dessus et
c'est probablement un argument ou une
attaque ses adversaires vont utiliser
contre lui le risque d' arrogant si
jamais la coalition a mené québec à 100
députés sur 125 ce sera un gouvernement
encore plus arrogant entre guillemets
est-ce que ça va porter comme attaquer
ce que les gens préfèrent pas avoir du
contenu bas vis-à-vis de ce genre d'
attaque on verra bien mais c'était un
risque c'est un danger en effet qui
guette toujours un peu monsieur monsieur
on lui a demandé combien
vous visez combien monsieur legault il à
10,63 pourquoi il est 63 je vous le
montre c'est la majorité donc pour
obtenir un gouvernement majoritaire et
fo et faire élire 63 députés au québec
c'est 125 du fait par deux + 1 donc
évidemment qu'il ne vise pas 63 ilves
beaucoup plus les 95
les sens peut-être que soient leurs
collègues étaient bonnes qu'elle s'est
constituée vous voulez perdre si jamais
vous en gagnez que 63 parce qu'il en a
76 je vous montre les tapis vous faites
bien de le rappeler sébastien l'état
actuel à l'assemblée nationale à la
dissolution il en a donc on le voit 76
pour la coalition vers québec 27 pour
les libéraux disent pour québec
solidaire c'est pour le parti québécois
il ya quatre députés indépendants et une
députée du parti conservateur madame
samson qui a rejoint qui était cas
qu'est -ce qui rejoint le parti
conservateur ensuite tout de table sur
avant qu'il ne parlait lui parlera plus
tard je vous le rappelle je vais fait
rappeler les heures des conférences de
presse ceux qui viennent de se joindre à
nous je vais vous rappeler la séquence
10 heures madame anglade à québec va
faire son point de presse devant son
autobus à 11 heures le premier ministre
va parler
11h45 paul st pierre plamondon
12h30 ce sera le point de presse du chef
conservateur et il termine la marge
gabriel nadeau dubois en début d'après
midi à 13h j'en profite pour dire
sébastien vous serez avec vos nouveaux
mordus ex comment vous appelez-vous
mordus de campagne mondiaux de câbles mt
sortant qui ne se représente pas mais
qui viennent évidemment une famille
politique ça promet ça parce qu'il y
aura des vrais débats et son attention
pour partisans se sont plus partisan
peut-être que les mordus de militants
pas mal que je sois je le sens ok le
tour de table sur la ligne de départ une
part avec avec croix comme élément
positif et avec quoi comme peut-être
bagages - policiers je vais acheter je
vais être vous l'homme aimé 3 mai 3 mai
trois maires je croise avec vous et
régis
les trois maires vous avez compris l'un
d'eux est plus mer mais c'est sais plus
mais vous êtes des observateurs de la
politique régis il parle avec beaucoup
de cartes dans son jeu monsieur la gaule
oui il part avec beaucoup de cartes dans
son jeu mais malgré tout cela moi je
passe qu'il voudra imposer des
thématiques identitaires justement pour
conserver le vote nationaliste alors on
entendre parler deux langues
on entend peu parler d'immigration mais
le problème dans tout ceci que c'est un
gars qui dirige la marne a4 a26 il y
avait quelque chose à faire et pouvait
le faire mais je m'attends absolument à
ce qu'il impose et puisse penser ce qui
est fait dans la dernière semaine des
thématiques identitaires grand chose je
le répète sa fortune est là ok donc vous
vous pensez que ce thème là va
autant tout cas il va vouloir l'imposer
la langue
rapport avec ottawa
noah 21 etc
manon
moi je pense qu'il vaut pour le
développement régional les votants thé
voire niveau répondre aux différents
besoins dans les différentes régions et
il ya des gens jouent aussi au niveau du
transport donc moi je pense qu'ils vont
parler parce que si c'est ce peut-être
qu'on va être un peu déçu mais je
penchais des enjeux en région et de gens
au québec et c'est là dessus que faux
débat faudel dans le respect avec la
diversité qu'on voit au départ
mais c'est le gouvernement introduit et
rouge fait il sait que si un enjeu qui
sort par exemple merci spécial il
prétendu pendables quatre heures avait
pas de problème de logement et là quand
j'ai vu que cette religion aux
reconnaissances problèmes de logement à
11000 d'exploitation s'il y avait de la
fonderie horne c'est pas simple pour
consentement le savait depuis les années
90 il ya aube solutions et donneurs
mineurs la sécurité à montréal une
surprise pour personne non plus ça fait
des années qu'ils attirent dans les rues
ou qu une solution à 250 millions non si
un trou de souris mais le magazine avoir
eu d'accord avec avec monsieur la bombe
mais le problème c'est que yahoo
pouvoir dépenser autant loi parce que si
cela était le cas il y aurait eu nous
référer immigration leur acier avec
l'influencé très bien très clair merci
avec nous je retrouve pierre reid
directeur général des élections du
québec que monsieur reid bonjour merci
d'être là
lévitation bon alors là on n'est plus
dans les mesures sanitaires
campagne qui va se dérouler
est ce que je peux dire totalement
normalement
non pas tout à fait normalement on a
quand même prévu la loi que les voit
quand même des mesures exceptionnelles
ou particulière pour les élections d'un
dieu je pense entre autres aux votes de
postale ou vote par correspondance qui
seront offerts à des personnes qui en
raison de leur état de santé
n'aurait pas la possibilité de se
déplacer d'également ce truc qui
pourrait contracter de l'aco vide dans
les prochains jours ou les prochaines
semaines donc à compter ces gens sont en
isolement les gens pourront également
voter
par correspondance donc il ya des trous
ce qui sont disponibles pour transmettre
et que même des électeurs pour venir
chercher la journée même du doigt mais
l'important c'est qu'ils puissent
ramener leurs trousses au plus tard à 20
heures le site world ok c'est important
donc même la journée du vote la fameuse
trou ce qu'on a connu ailleurs dans
l'autre élection fédérale va pouvoir
être facilement disponibles remplies à
la maison par la personne qui peut pas
sortir ou qui est mieux pour sortir et
rapportés avant 20 heures oui les gens
devront en faire la demande un proche
pour le mieux chercher la trousse et à
ce moment là le retour de leur tour
doivent absolument voir lui alain 20h le
bon et vous estimer à combien le
pourcentage de gens qui vont vouloir
voter comme ça
c'est les psy mail mais disons qu'on
s'est préparé pour on a quand même un
peu plus de 150000 trop ce qu'ils seront
prêts pour
éventuellement répondre à la demande de
ces personnes dehors qui sont dans cette
situation sera peu près 6 millions
d'électeurs inscrits au québec est ce
que le recrutement est un casse tête
monsieur ries par là qu'on voit monsieur
legault le moment qui s'installe et qui
va signer les décrets
le conseil des ministres a adopté le
décret suivant qui vous puis de les
sanctionner fourneaux de sa majesté
décret concernant la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale du québec et la
convocation d'une nouvelle assemblée
et le décret concernant la tenue
d'élections générales au québec
c'est zizou
il joue
mais vous comme si l'affairé
donc à part
voilà
valet
regarde
je regarde si
bonne campagne tout le monde a répété le
premier ministre après que le lieutenant
gouverneur est signé les décrets qui
dissout les l'assemblée législative du
québec des députés dont qui sont
maintenant des candidats dans toutes les
régions du québec dans toutes les
circonscriptions les 125 alors voilà
donc c'est vrai monsieur reid vous aurez
à gérer des élections qu'est ce que ça a
changé dans votre vie les élections à
date fixe
balai dans les élections à date fixe en
faciliter notre travail au niveau de
l'organisation de la planification
des vols de matériel électoral a été
transmis dans les bureaux des directeurs
directrices du scrutin il ya déjà
presque deux semaines donc les bureaux
sont les directeurs et directrices sont
prêts à accueillir vont ouvrir leurs
bureaux dans la journée vous domaine
[Musique]
mise en oeuvre pour accueillir des
directeurs demande des formations ont
vite en action
dernière chose avant de vous laisser
aller le 9 connu des des bureaux de vote
où il y avait des files épouvantable
compte tenu du manque de personnel ce
que ça c'est pas une de vos grandes
craintes
le personnel le recrutement du personnel
est toujours un enjeu c'est à chaque
élection écoutez la même énergie et
environnement
santé et d'identité encore défendre
les cassandre
j'ai nommé d'éducation connu
éducation at-il dit monsieur legault en
premier va se commet dans un instant on
va l'écouter nous serine pardonnez nous
on va aller vous rejoins d'après façon
ça vous intéresse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on a le son de l'intérieur on se
pince excuses mesdames et messieurs on
travaille là dessus
question est ce qu'on a le son de
véronique qui a été très vive equidia
vous n'avez pas nommé l'éducation et oui
j'ai une amie l'éducation premier donc
ça reste
un dossier prioritaire pour moi et là
voilà il est à bord de son autobus si on
va le revoir monsieur legault à 11h lors
d'un point de presse dans toutes les
questions seront posées à ce moment là
c'est vraiment parti monsieur ries dont
je complète avec vous pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre bon au défi où ce sud
évident mais est ce que vous avez en
main à ses membres déjà inscrits pour
que ça se déroule roule rondement dans
les bureaux de vote
en fait que les gens peuvent postuler en
ligne depuis quand même quelques
semaines le recrutement du personnel va
se faire à compter du 7 au 8 octobre
répondent aux gens pour déjà transmis de
demande en raison du fait que les partis
politiques doivent jusqu'au 7 septembre
fourni leurs recommandations pour les
postes de scrutateurs de gendt à une
fois passée cette date nous allons
pouvoir faire de la baule c'est un jeu
tient souligné que pour la première fois
les jeunes de 16 et 17 ans pour pouvoir
agir quand même super son électorat donc
on discute at her et secrétaire qui est
très important
donc en fait trop je pense qu'on est en
mesure de relever le défi comme à chaque
fois de recruter le nombre suffisant
parce qu on les engage il y à la
formation de ces personnes de donner de
meilleurs services je souligne que le 25
et 26 septembre chez le vote par
anticipation c'est de toujours de plus
en plus populaire n'est ce pas moi je
vous dis que pour le vote par
anticipation 2018 l'ensemble parce que
pour être voté dans les bureaux
directeurs du scrutin les grog estime de
votre étudiant le vote à domicile et
tout ça c'est plus de 25% des gens qui
ont voté avant le 3 comme en 2010 qu'est
ce qu'est ce qui est bien sébastien
humain fait et une anecdote sur
l'affichage là vous avez vu pousser
cette nuit toutes sortes d' affiches
dans vos quartiers à montayral manger et
vous dites donc avant même le
déclenchement des élections le woudy les
élections étaient pas déclencher comment
ça se fait qu'ils ont droit de faire ça
le dge n'ont encore pas l'affichage
avant le déclenchement officiel des
élections étaient des règlements
municipaux mais donc c'est pas illégal
c'est la pression puis je voulais
apporter d'affiché avant même le
déclenchement des élections et
l'anecdote c'est qu'en 2012 si ma
mémoire est fidèle quand le premier
ministre charest est sorti par la porte
que vous avez vu de l'édifice du premier
ministre monsieur legault sortie tout à
l'heure le parti québécois avait tapissé
les lampadaires qui le séparait sur la
route qui le séparait de son bureau
bureau du lieutenant-gouverneur dont
cathy lever la tête il voyait des images
de pauline marois donc on avait pris
soin de tapis si la rue des
parlementaires
celui donc pour ce qui des dépenses
prix lecteurs prêts
période électorale là est ce que ça ne
vient pas de casse tête les gens qui ont
le monde non seulement il ya des
dépenses mais il ya des annonces sur des
affiches est-ce qu'on a un examen à
faire pour mieux encadrer ces ou pas
en fait c'était suivi que des gens
devaient fait en 2018 qui avait quand
même beaucoup de social qui est
intervenu en période préélectorale nous
avons suivi cette année également et
puis les dépenses pré électorales qui
ont effectué par les partis politiques
bas niveau rend compte aussi plus dans
leur rapport annuel financés et nous
banned from d'analystes de tout ça et si
de soissons l'exigent on a livré avec
des propositions très tard pour que nous
soumettrons aux législateurs et à la
discussion de tous bords je vous
souhaite une bonne campagne électorale
monsieur uriner genou la souhaite donc
que ça est rondement et on va suivre ça
tous les jours merci beaucoup nous avons
parlé en tirer merci beaucoup de
journaux et au revoir
si vous avez été attentifs aux bulletins
d'informations nouvelles vous si vous
avez lu les journaux cet été le sujet
qui ressortit puis luc ferrandez 0 de
découverte moi j'étais en abitibi cet
été les gens me disaient les montréalais
vient de découvrir que ça pollue la
fonderie horne fait 40 ans qu'on le dit
il ya un éveil pourquoi on préfère des
cessions et des grandes études pourquoi
on a tant parlé là beaucoup parce que le
docteur arruda
c'est notre collègue gerber qui avec
avait appris qui a pris qui nous a
appris que doctor who davet
oblitéré un document avait fait enlever
un document et c'est ça qui à repartir
ce dossier-là importuns de
jusqu'où on doit laisser polluer des
entreprises qui ont un droit acquis
historiques c'est le cas de la fonderie
horne
sébastien donc tout ça pour dire que
rouyn noranda
ça sera deux circonscriptions surveiller
en abitibi elle est détenue par québec
solidaire la cac il présente l'ancien
député libéral daniel bernard qui était
député libéral au tournant des années
2000 il avait une autre candidate mais
qui s'est désisté pour des raisons
personnelles et donc monsieur bernard a
pris le relais abitibi témiscamingue en
gros ce sont trois circonscriptions donc
c'est pas ce qui va faire la différence
dans le vote le soir du scrutin mais
quand même c'est une région sur
lesquelles on va porter une attention
justement à cause de rouyn noranda
témiscamingue il faut toujours dire le
témiscamingue patrice parce que les gens
du témiscamingue que j'adore si un
j'adore
jeudi une des plus belles régions du
québec autres régions chouchou c'est ma
région je ne mets pas pour des raisons
électorales mais une région
extraordinaire c'est comme l'estrie il
ya soixante dix ans c'est magnifique bon
bref ministre lessard artérielle et
député de québec solidaire dans cette
circonscription la cac avait des visées
sur cette circonscription en se disant
avec la tâche d'huile de la caq les
notre force dans les régions du québec
on pourrait aller chercher l'habitude
rouyn noranda témiscamingue
sauf qu'on a un sérieux doute avec la
fournir aux reins évidemment comment ça
va jouer dans l'élection est-ce que ça
va permettre à madame lessard terriens
demain de garde et de conserver cette
circonscription pour québec solidaire on
verra bien pasquet d'abitibi-ouest
abitibi est
l'ancienne circonscription de françois
gendron série est est ce que la caq peut
conserver six circonscriptions est ce
que le débat sur la fonderie horne sur
l'environnement sur la qualité de l'air
parce qu'on change un peu bas de
lorgnette sur le débat sur
l'environnement on en parle de façon
avec la lorgnette de la santé publique
plutôt que de la question de réduction
des gaz à effet serre en abitibi
témiscamingue en particulier donc est-ce
que lala quatre blocs être capable de
maintenir ces deux circonscriptions avec
ce qui s'est passé avec la ford et ron
questions sur la ligne des banques oui
chanteur juste ajouté au sujet de la
fonderie horne bien au sujet des claques
min
c'est de plus en plus un sujet de
préoccupation dans de vastes régions du
québec la petite nation pour un homme et
une parce que je suis plus branché
possède là mais ça a commencé doucement
mais à chaque fois que je vais sur les
pages facebook la région ça prend de
l'ampleur ça prend de l'ampleur et c'est
un peu en collision avec les aspirations
énergétique de françois legault eu
l'idée de faire du québec la capitale
des minéraux précieux pour les batteries
c'est aussi lors du jour de justin
trudeau c'est un sujet qui coûte mais je
ne crois pas moi qui va être escamotable
en campagne électorale parce que le
niveau d'inquiétude ça va jusqu'à 10 go
et les autorités municipales qui
demandait qu'on exemple la région de
ligue ou de clem minier jusqu'à présent
ça a été refusé c'est un des sujets dont
qui fait pas encore les manchettes mais
quand on est sur le terrain on l'entend
beaucoup plus que même le coût de la vie
parce que ça parle de la vie des gens
comme le cas de la fonderie neurones
c'est mais
l'opposition entre
lépingle a tiré du jeu de la lutte aux
changements climatiques et ce qui se
passe sur le terrain me semble de plus
en plus évident voilà une diaw bordeaux
vous êtes à rouyn noranda on voyait
revenir sur le jeu en temps de manon cyr
est élu tu es et régis sur l'ailé club
c'est comme si quand c'est en abitibi
puis dans le grand nord aux bons mais ça
y est ça pollue les mines mais le les
clean comme chantal c'est partout parce
que devenir la batterie sur une chose il
faut aller chercher les métaux dans dans
le sol on va y revenir guillaume renaut
bonjour à roye un oiseau patrice alors
évidemment il ya la fonderie on ya
d'autres enjeux également chez vous et
plus parler des gens évidemment oui
d'abord il sera question de manque de
personnel notamment en santé la région
est bien habitués à des bris de service
en période estivale en raison de cette
pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui est déjà
bien présente depuis plusieurs années
cet été c'est l'urgence de témiscamingue
kipawa qui demeure fermé depuis juin le
soir et la nuit on se rappelle également
de cette fermeture de l'urgence acenta
qui avait provoqué beaucoup de
mécontentement l an dernier et au début
de cette année évidemment comme vous
l'avez mentionné sera beaucoup question
de ce dossier de la qualité de l'air à
rouyn noranda après des semaines
d'incertitudes le ministre de
l'environnement compte maintenant
instaurer une norme de 15 nanogrammes
par mètre cube d'air pour les émissions
d'arsenic à la fonderie ont ici à rouyn
noranda ça provient d'une recommandation
de la santé publique mais ça déçoit
plusieurs acteurs régionaux étant donné
que cette norme demain 5 fois plus élevé
que la norme québécoise soit 3
nanogrammes par mètre cube ça occupera
certainement une bonne partie de cette
campagne électorale il sera également
question de pénurie de logements et 2 de
la vie donc j'ai pu m'entretenir avec
certains électeurs je propose d'écouter
quelques extraits
l'enjeu qui me touchait 6 au niveau des
sites ma place en garderie c'est ça que
je trouve que pour les
mamans les parents qui en empêche troc
est un dangereux à ces problématiques
évidemment on a le problème de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui nous guérir
complètement depuis des années et moi
c'est sûr que toutes les parties qui
sont par le côté vert plus écologique et
tout sur moi c'est sûr que c'est dans
mes valeurs les enjeux environnementaux
liés aux émissions d'arsenic de la
fonderie on entend beaucoup parler ces
dernières semaines c'est vrai que ça a
des répercussions majeures
donc ce sans doute intéressante pour
tous ces enjeux mais spécialement pour
la qualité de l'air à rouyn noranda la
cac n'a toujours pas proposé
d'échéancier clair pour l'application de
cette norme de 3 dans nos grands mâts
rouyn noranda québec solidaire s'est
déjà engagé à le faire d'ici quatre ans
il y perd tout pouvant donc ce sera à
suivre dans cette campagne qui débute
aujourd'hui très bien mais encore oui et
merci beaucoup guillaume très apprécié
encore faut-il que la fonderie horne se
disent capables se disent incapables
donc la question c'est est ce qu'on vous
faire mon lit la salle il petite
anecdote quand québec solidaire a rendu
public son slogan changer d'air la
première personne le matin à 7 heures le
matin que texter gabriel nadeau dubois
s'était emily's les sens terrien le
député de rouyn noranda en disant merci
pour le slogan changer d'ère je n'oublie
pas ce que la beauce est un enjeu très
important de la campagne et québec
solidaire n'était pas certain de pouvoir
regarder rouyn noranda lors elle n'est
toujours pas certaine de garder loin
noranda québec ces dames mais en même
temps ça donnait vraiment coup de pouce
et qu est le ce qui s'est passé cet été
la baule donc on savait une batterie
très intéressante luckman ont érigé sur
ce que chante elle parlait de sucre m et
là c'est dans le sud c'est dans le
québec peuple et c'est là le québec très
peuplée très densifier peuplé cas et je
le disais avec ironie mais quand stan
abitibi légende est bon mais c'est pas
grave là c'est la bosse et loin devant
nous ça nous concerne pas là
est ce que ça peut devenir ce sujet là
un enjeu où
je commence avec vous mais non c'est
trop loin c'est pas assez concentrés que
vous en pensez
mais moi je pense que dans le nord du
québec ou même en abitibi témiscamingue
les régions traditionnellement minière
ce que vous parle de plus en plus les
enjeux c'est plus de dieu où en es-tu
vraiment une gagne de colonisé c'est à
dire que les entreprises viennent
exploiter les ressources puis à pas sans
voir de véritables retombées ont relevé
des progrès ceci étant dit il ya eu des
améliorations dernières années mais moi
je veut s'ouvrir parce que l'on partage
un territoire dans le nord québécois
auprès on veut développer des mines dans
l'enquêté quoi mais quand ça arrive dans
une note tout à coup c'est plus un
michel moi je sens qu'une phénomène pas
dans le coup récemment pour moi c'est
préoccupant par ceci étant dit c'est
ceux de la fonderie en bas rhin et pas
que je pense même sur la perception des
gens par rapport au développement mini
gens vous disent recevoir moins
qu'indiqué même polluent à une époque
les mines polluée il faut les surveiller
il faut s'assurer qu'un caddie
développement parce que nous on a des
noms québécois dans l'eau du québec une
convention de la baie james à un régime
particulier au niveau de l'environnement
donc il ya des choses qui sont faits
pour s'assurer quelques développe une
nouvelle mine on respecte
l'environnement où on fait avec le moins
d'impact possible ce 7 ans résident chez
nous l'enjeu si les retombées
économiques et sociales puis là la
volonté de développer une expertise unis
travaillent pour notre front est a moi
des résidents et non juste du
travailleur qui font du flash et ça va
bien intégré par daniel herlemme ans
j'ai rajouté un petit ilyès vous avez
l'ancien maire de senneterre monsieur
jean maurice mann ou bien qu'ils se
présentent au parti libéral on verra
avec la division d'honneur ne sera
ok oui parce que j'ai rien fait qu tu
mens des histoires de deux candidats qui
ont beaucoup de renommée qui ont dû
tirant d'eau dans certaines régions le
quai
le qui régissent quand même sur la
question des maines le convoi se
développer des clubs qui poussent comme
des champignons rouge un peu partout en
lutte qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais j'en pense que quand on se disait
que la coi qui est round cheville pour
les questions d'un des mines
le ministère des ressources à kirill a
répondu à la gueule des rideaux qui
voulait refaire son plan d'aménagement
du territoire le radis blanc bio on va
pas protéger un espace vert et le mont
rigaud
voyons le mont rigaud c'est un espace
boisé qui n'est pas encore en espace
protégé mais c'est un espace extrêmement
important pour la région de même que les
parcs nationaux raté
quatre hors attendait à dire ou haute il
ya des endroits où on ne peut pas parler
glem unis les endroits où on y repense
et ils sont et ont bondi sur la balle
pour les la moitié de mes ont toujours
répondu à rigaud on
l'a vu avec un de ville sur la route je
le regarde la caq c'est fait on va
enrichir les québécois
sans exception par une veuve n'importe
où sur le bébé et soeurs faut que ce
soit corrigé immédiatement
moi je pense que c'est comme les lignes
de haute tension personnel contre indoor
pas surtaxés pour exactement 4 allée des
lignes des nations unies vient de
partout les gens réagissent
reges sujet un portable ou aimer sting
des temps serait un feu notre concert ou
à ne pas dire que le lac osisko est mort
et qui a pas un poisson qui vivent une
seule journée le bac et sa voisine la
faune des douanes ceci dit la maman du
gouvernement comprennent qu'on ne peut
pas donner des clés d'un des milieux
urbains où ce mur mais s'est terminée
cette époque-là par ailleurs quand on
voit le comportement de la chine et de
la russie qui sont les principaux
producteurs de terres rares des métaux
rares tout leur fille danse / se demande
comment on va pouvoir s'en priver a
provisionné dans l'avenir le québec peut
jouer un rôle mais l'été avance est au
dessus 52e pas banal alors il faut que
le grand dam en se donnant plein
maintenant menant à vaison oui ça
produit généralement les maths mais ça
se modernise aussi alors le québec
avantage à se donner un plan d'action je
pense qu'il en a même eu de mettre en
action pour devenir un producteur de
terreur mais pas dans des lieux qui sont
habitées ou des livres voisines et des
villes sélectionnées plus possible
aujourd'hui très bien merci on voit
l'autobus de campagne de dominique
anglade elle est donc la première qui va
venir devant les journalistes répondre
aux questions point de presse mais sur
ces questions là ça va être intéressant
de voir l'attitude du parti libéral du
québec devant tous ses éclats bon québec
solidaire sont pas mal écrit dans le
ciel leur position pire on la connaît
d'ailleurs mais le parti libéral face à
ce développement en leur potentiel à
batterie elle aussi à ce discours là
donc oui le pass libéré qui s'est fait
voler son étiquette de partie de
l'économie qui veut retrouver cette
étiquette de parti d'économies mais
c'est délicat ici parce qu'il ya à la
fois l'environnement et le développement
économique en principe on appelle ça du
développement durable met donc les
minières ont une peau très belle fiche
de feuille de route en matière
d'environnement alors comment développer
le québec et en faire une force
économique tout en préservant
l'environnement c'est
un beau débat parlez-moi des défis de
madame anglade qu'on va entendre dans
une seconde ils sont nombreux vous allez
me dire mais comment qu'est-ce qu'elle
partie elle peut jouer l'aller pour vous
donner une idée des difficultés du parti
et libérale son premier rassemblement
aujourd'hui dans la fontaine qui est une
circonscription qu'elle a remporté pas
plus de vingt mille voix la dernière
fois ça vous donne une idée des
difficultés du parti on ne devrait pas
lancer une campagne dans la fontaine qui
ont le parti libéral normalement donc
oui on est sur la défensive nord-est de
l'île qui tenait un côté sur certains
normalement pour les libéraux donc on
est vraiment à défensive assez de garder
les circonscriptions qu'on a déjà
capable de limiter les dégâts et si on
est chanceux peut-être être capable de
faire un ou deux gains dans des
circonscriptions qui ont déjà été
libérale bon ça par exemple washington
sur la montérégie que déjà été libérale
qui avait été gagné par moins de 1000
voix par la cac mais la faiblesse des
libéraux chez les francophones et on
voyait revenir tout au long de la
campagne fait en sorte que ce type de
circonscription là actuellement hors de
portée peut-être que pendant la campagne
on va voir une remontée que ce sera
possible actuellement on s'accroche à
nos bastions et quand on peut perdre
presque toutes les circonscriptions de
laval peut-être prochain m'aider ça veut
dire qu'on est vraiment dans le trouble
parce que ce sont des circonscriptions
normalement qui sont dévolues au parti
libéral fils d'aller plus bas alec
chante elle parlait du
chanteur dans le vote chez les
francophones le léger hier leur donnait
7 % moment là voici madame anglet qui
arrive du sud a les plus beaux on va
l'écouter convié toute photo
d'ailleurs
alors bonjour bonjour à tous très
content d'être avec vous ce matin en
fait un peu fébrile hier j'avais des
papillons dans l'estomac ce matin je me
je me sens d'attaqué me sens d'attaqué
pour la campagne la campagne qui s'en
vient et je vous dirais la chose
suivante
on va mettre aujourd'hui je vais m
françois legault au défi sur l'économie
l'économie va être la question de l'urne
et je mets françois legault au défi
d'aller répéter que la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre ça a été une mauvaise de
bonnes nouvelles
je mets au défi d'aller voir des parents
dont les enfants n'ont pas d'enseignants
aujourd'hui pour les prochaines semaines
je le mets au défi d'aller voir des
entrepreneurs qui sont obligés de fermer
leur entreprise
parce que justement ils n'ont pas
suffisamment de main d'oeuvre je mets au
défi aussi d'aller voir des gens comme
jane est que j'ai rencontrés puis de
leur dire que la question dans les jt
hsl décision pas de service c'est parce
qu'ils ont pas de main d'oeuvre quand je
dis que la question de lui on va être la
question de l'économie je pense au coût
de la vie on a plusieurs familles
aujourd'hui qui sont pas capable de
joindre les deux bouts là qui doivent
décider entre payer le loyer ou acheter
de la nourriture
c'est pas acceptable qu'il nous faut des
propositions concrètes est ce qu'on va
faire dans les prochaines semaines c'est
justement à la rencontre des québécois
pour qu'ils découvrent toutes les
propositions qu'on a à faire par rapport
par rapport au coût de la vie par
rapport à l'économie
quand on parle d'économie on parle
également d'écologie nous faut un projet
de société un grand projet un grand
projet auquel le parti libéral a
vraiment habitué les québécois et ce
grand projet c'est eko eko pour écologie
échos pour économie ça va faire partie
des éléments essentiels
encore une fois pour nous la question du
rhône ça va être sur les comics
pourquoi filet connu parce que pour
l'instant relativement prédécesseur et
équipé canam et kassav
l'équipe économique et très dernier je
vous dirai quand on pense que marwa
risky c'est une fiscalité quand on pense
qu'on a la mine touré keita puis
étudiant en économie quand on pense
qu'on a un éric feydel beauchemin qui
lui a passé 30 ans dans le milieu
bancaire à la scotia quand on pense à
des entrepreneurs comme françois vice
quand on pense à des désirs et maigreux
qui ont été reconnus et renommé pour
bien comprendre les enjeux en matière de
changements climatiques et d'économie
quand on pense que quand on pense que
moi même j'ai occupé la fonction de
ministre de l'économie et du travail fdt
a tant dans le secteur je pense qu'on a
la meilleure équipe économique
nous allons annoncer d'autres
candidatures de riz vous avez choisi
comme président en campagne carlos
leitao est ce que ça veut dire que si
vous revenez au pouvoir comme ce que les
québécois ont connu valérie table l
équilibre budgétaire et ça va peut-être
se faire de façon douloureuse comme ça
s'est développé l'objectif pour nous
aujourd'hui quand on parle d'économie
c'est s'assurer qu'on répond aux besoins
du coût de la vie d'abord et avant tout
ça ça veut dire que les québécois
doivent our avoir de l'argent dans leurs
poches
avoir de l'argent dans leurs poches ça
ça veut dire qu'il va avoir des
propositions concrètes pour réduire pour
les québécois pour réduire les le taux
d'imposition pour réduire les taxes pour
les québécois de la classe moyenne
s'assurer également qu'on donne de l'air
ou aux personnes aînées parce que la
seule chose qu'elle demande pas
aujourd'hui la seule chose qu'elle vend
pas aujourd'hui c'est les revenus pour
nos élus et ce
alors nous allons
nous ce n'est pas le moment de réduire
les dépenses en fonction de ça parce que
au contraire les gens ont besoin d'avoir
de l'ère des gens ont besoin d'avoir des
mesures claires pour passer à travers la
situation actuelle c'est pour ça que la
réduction du fardeau fiscal est
importante c'est pour çà également qu'il
faut penser à nos aînés il faut penser à
nos familles l'économie comme étape
les indicateurs économiques au quai des
dents mais
c'est la croissance des revenus du
gouvernement qui sont peut-être bon mais
pas la croissance dans les poches des
québécois on va le dire sans
parler aux entreprises j'entendais
parler le président de la chambre de
commerce de montréal qu'est ce qui nous
a dit le plus grand frein économique
aujourd'hui c'est la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre on à 270 milles emplois vacants
ça a des conséquences directes sur les
services à la population en santé en
éducation c'est la rentrée scolaire
aujourd'hui vous avez des enfants vous
avez des enfants vous savez qu'il ya des
enseignants qui seront pas au rendez
vous parce qu on est en pénurie on tape
hendrick personnel alors sept ans je
l'aï les critiques est ce que j'ai
surtout entendu dire le milieu des
affaires c'est pénurie c'est un frein à
leur développement économique mais c'est
surtout le parti libéral qui est le
mieux placé pour
on alors on va lancer aujourd'hui encore
on sera à 110 on va finir 125 dans les
prochains jours
on était autrefois un grand pas le parti
n'est plus ce qu'il était le parti
d'économies partie verra au jour
j'ai une chose à dire à françois legault
personne ne peut s'appeler partie de
l'économie s'il n'est pas capable de
reconnaître que le frein principal
aujourd'hui à notre développement
économique c'est la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre et ça il a nié tout le long et
continue de lui je le mets au défi
aujourd'hui de dire
de l'économie absolument et parce qu'on
reconnaît les véritables enjeux pense
qu'on reconnaît que les freins à la
croissance c'est justement la question
la question de la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre parce qu'on reconnaît que le
coût de la vie que les gens de la
difficulté à résoudre c'est pas des
chèques de 500 pièces qui va régler
problème ce sont des mesures à long
terme parce qu'on reconnaît également
que notre avenir passe par un véritable
projet de société qui conjugue écologie
et économie et ça c est qu c'est le
projet de société qu'on présente et si
on n'a pas compris que l'économie se
conjugue avec l'écologie qu'on n'a pas
compris que la main d'oeuvre est un
frein essentiel on n'a rien compris de
l'économie du québec un jour c'est
pourquoi le d'abord il francophone je
suis francophone de tacite pour ça dans
les sondages si vous êtes encore ce
grand parti comme en survêt pro capable
d'aller chercher le lecteur francophone
une campagne électorale
on repart les compteurs à zéro on repart
les compteurs à zéro pour aller à la
rencontre des québécois pour que
découvrent les pois les propositions
qu'on a à faire c'est pour ça que je
suis moi je suis enthousiaste à l'idée
de
les francophones sont des gens comme
comme vous et moi comme tout le monde
qui ont eux aussi envie de s'assurer
qu'on soit capable de régler les anges
et de coups de l'est comment les
compositions les propositions qu'on va
un niveau répondre à ces enjeux là
spécifié en 36 jours
bonjour vous aviez pas été en mesure
d'exprimer aucune inquiétude
était qu'ils étaient constatés alors que
quelques heures jours plus tard monsieur
trudeau lui même exprimé sa
préoccupation donc aujourd'hui de voir
me dire ça vous inquiète ab j'ai utilisé
le mot préoccupant cette journée là j'ai
utilisé le mot de recul du français au
centre ville de montréal je pouvais
utiliser le mot inquiétude si vous
voulez la question du français sera
toujours une question fondamentale on
est 2 % de francophones en amérique du
nord et va rester demeurant un enjeu il
faut toujours continuer de défendre les
français
non je ne joue pas inquiétude voire
suisse est le synonyme de sur habitat
vous êtes bien placés pour le faire en
plus françois choisi des synonymes
inquiétudes préoccupations déclin le
message à envoyer ses dires on se soit
toujours un enjeu qui va falloir qu'on
amène des mesures c'est pour ça qu'on a
proposé 27 mesures place dans votre
parti pour ce jeu des finances et la
police parce que vous avez déjà eu une
candidate à l'investiture dans bourassa
sous ring même les vieux bouger qui est
elle
la position est très claire par rapport
à ça il faut faire trois choses
premièrement au contraire augmenter les
effectifs hors matière dans en matière
de police puis si on l'a dit cette
semaine c'est important de faire pour
assurer la sécurité dans
dans morale dans l'aval également
deuxièmement s'assurer d'un financement
adéquat pour la ville pour s'assurer
qu'elles répondent aux besoins il ne pas
avoir à demander de l'argent chaque fois
que ça se produit et troisièmement et
j'insiste là dessus la question de la
prévention la prévention c'est essentiel
on a des organismes et ils ne sont plus
capables de suffire à la demande et aux
besoins sur le terrain et ça on n'en
fait pas assez de prévention sur lequel
on n'est pas en faveur du des
financements de la police je vais le
dire on en faveur de faire en sorte
qu'on finance la police adéquatement
confinance municipalité puis qu'on soit
en relation en commun et que et et que
et que on soit capable de faire de la
prévention la
france est sur cinq est ce que ça vaut
premièrement je me serais à la veille et
ça ça a l'air d'une annonce totalement
improvisée à la veille à la veille des
élections ça fait des mois qu'on réclame
des sommes additionnelles notamment pour
la police fait pour la prévention
alors je pense qu'on est très en retard
ça démontre que les professionnels le la
prévention encore beaucoup de travail à
faire
ben c'est à la veille d'un déclenchement
dirais quand on a attendu la dernière
minute pour annoncer quelque chose alors
qu'on sait depuis des mois qui a des
envies alors qu on s'époumone depuis des
mois à dire que ça nous prend davantage
d'argent notamment
une certaine littoral y sont à la veille
des élections
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui on remet
les compteurs les compteurs à zéro on
remet les compteurs à zéro on part en
campagne électorale les gens pouvaient
avoir les tous les partis vous savez
comment qu'on a eu un deux en deux ans
plus de pandémie qui aura été difficile
pour tout le monde mais parce que les
gens vont regarder ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est encore une fois la
question de lui on va être sur
l'économie et on sera au rendez vous
parce que on est ce qu'ils auront les
meilleurs proposants
on est aujourd'hui avec vous ici à
québec on voit est à montréal tantôt de
retour à québec dès demain on sera en
estrie on s'en doutait mais on sera
partout pendant toute la campagne
électorale de londres et à québec cette
semaine vous avez le parti annoncé les
comptes de 52 yards tels les
propositions pour la capitale nationale
vous étiez absent avez vous laissé
tomber déjà la région de la
capitale-nationale absolument pas vous
voyez ici aujourd'hui dans la capitale
nationale vous allez me voir encore ici
demain dans la capitale nationale et
donc vous allez continuer à me voir ici
pour les enjeux pour pour les anges de
la région
faire découvrir toutes les propositions
qu'on aime me faire découvrir moi même
aussi que les gens apprennent à voir
quel genre de personne je suis je vois
une dame qui hoche de la tête en arrière
qu'elle aime bien d'accord avec ça mais
de faire découvrir qui je suis le genre
de leader que je suis aussi à inclure
tout le monde à faire en sorte qu'on
soit une équipe qui on réfléchisse
ensemble à trouver ses solutions qu'on
amène aux québécois
voit suffisamment pas suffisamment parce
que on a eu deux ans où on n'a pas eu
cette chance ça et c'est pour ça qu'il
ne faut pas nier électorale c'est
important pour moi de campagne c'est le
coeur de la démocratie
c'est un moment extrêmement important
tout le monde part avec un sur un pied
d'égalité pour dire voici ce qu'on a à
offrir aux québécois puis l'opportunité
pour les coins et qu'il ait pas de
choisir le
déjà vu le parti libéral attendent le
déclenchement des élections pour
présenter des candidatures économie ça a
été le cas avec
gimbert est ce qu'on doit décoller
puisque vous faites de l'économie votre
priorité au jour que les prochaines
candidatures
ce que vous devez décoder c'est qu'on a
déjà une équipe économique et a guéri
avec nous si ce qu'on a déjà une équipe
économique quand j'en parlais de marwa
risqué quand je parlais de françois va
être réparée de frais de bouche mais
quand je parlais des personnes qui ont
décidé de se joindre à nous c'est déjà
une équipe économie plus quand c'est
donc
la dernière fois que nous avions fait
campagne des candidats annoncés donc ce
très cohérent avec ce qu'on a fait par
le passé
[Musique]
la perception générale x et une campagne
ce sera une campagne pour le parti
libéral the lights et sur la défense non
nous allons être à l'offensive sur
l'économie la qui sont principal la
question de l'urne sera l'économie
pourquoi parce que françois legault
répète depuis des années que le manque
de main d'oeuvre était une bonne
nouvelle et ce n'est pas le cas je les
invite à les rencontrer des gens qui
n'ont pas de d'enseignants dans leurs
écoles qui n'ont pas des infirmières des
infirmières sont épuisés de je l'invite
à rencontrer des entrepreneurs qui
n'arrivent pas à trouver des employés
c'est une situation critique au pour le
québec qui le françois legault continue
à dire que c'est une bonne nouvelle
j québécois vont avoir de la difficulté
à joindre les deux bouts alors les
questions économiques montrent une des
questions économiques pour le long cours
faire des changements pour aider les
familles pourrait aider les aînés
adjoint du tout goût ça va être une
campagne au sujet de l'économie parce
que la société aux besoins d'un projet à
long terme et si notre adn ekoué coup
pour économie etc ou pur écologie c'est
la façon dont on réfléchit à l'économie
pour le futur
l'économie au québec
va très bien selon certaines
selon certains indicateurs on est en
train de fermer l'écart avec l'ontario
en fait
alors l'économie semble très bien ali
alors de montagne par kehl québécois si
ça se fait sur meilleur aujourd'hui
qu'il ya quatre ans vont dire non en
fait les gens n'ont pas autant d'argent
dans leurs poches les gens souffrent de
l'inflation les gens doivent choisir
entre nourrir leur famille ou payer le
loyer la situation dans laquelle on se
trouve maintenant et aucune mesure de
court terme vont redresser cette
situation nous avons des propositions
pour le long terme
madame anglade qui dit vouloir faire de
l'économie la question essentielle de
cette campagne électorale elle dit que
monsieur legault ne prend pas assez au
sérieux la pénurie de main d'oeuvre donc
on sent que ça sera une des lignes de
force de son plaidoyer que de rappeler
aux gens que le parti libéral du québec
à une historique
de partis champion de l'économie titre
que la cac et allait ravir de façon
concrète au cours des dernières années
madame à anglade
on lui demandait ce que vous avez une
équipe économique fort justement elle
parle de marwa risky le père de carlos
l'état ou qui est le président de la
campagne qui n'est pas candidat l'ancien
ministre des finances le tour de table
madame anglade en fait sébastien n'a pas
le choix que de parler de soldes il faut
qu'elles sucent qu'ils se montrent comme
étant la championne d'économie de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre le défi de
madame anglade c'est de se définir elle
comme chef première ministrable
peut-être de définir ce qu'est le parti
libéral on voit pourquoi si on vote pour
le parti libéral depuis quatre ans comme
perdu les repères vis-à-vis du parti
libéral qui est en recherche d'identité
et là elle seule elle revient sur l'adn
du parti libéral l'économie en essayant
d'imposer ce thème là comme la question
décisive la question de l'homme mais
elle doit se définir elle-même définir
le parti et il est en examen madame
anglade parce que on parle beaucoup de
son avenir à l'issue de cette campagne
électorale l'impression qu'on a au plq
c'est que si elle réussit à sauver les
meubles autour de 27 29 30
circonscriptions
on pourrait lui donner une deuxième
chance mais si c'est plus boxer zanon 27
lanvin il en avait 29 à l'élection de
2018 et ils en ont 27 en effet parce
qu'ils ont perdu 2 en cours de route
mais donc il faut qu'elle arrive à un
résultat similaire aux élections du 18
où meilleur c'est moins bon il y aura
certainement des murmures à des
questions qui se poseront sur son les
luges donc des filles de madame ans de
la tour de table chantal un pas certaine
que quelle équipe économique pour porter
le thème quelle heure elle même choisi
c'est un étrange choix
quand on pense par exemple questions
d'environnement en france à québec celui
là et on pense talon d'achille pour de
quoi le faire venir québec mais je suis
pas convaincu quoi qu'on dise son
inflation que
les québécois regardent le gouvernement
legault anzin c'est un gouvernement qui
est pas capable de gérer l'économie ce
serait même probablement plutôt le
contraire avant quand on sait la
question de l'homme cedh économie c'est
comme se mettre un autre fardeau sur les
épaules je l'écoutais aussi et je me
disais finalement le parti libéral du
québec jean charest en particulier
souvent sauvé sa mise en tout ou en
partie en martelant l'histoire du
référendum que le pq est là l'absence de
cette capacité de dire ça c'est comme ci
a laissé un grand vide dans le discours
et si ce monsieur l'état où étaient
candidats pour précédente campagne ça et
des
mémés la personne qu'on identifie de
plus gestion économique dans l'équipe
libérale et pas sur les rangs pour
devenir ministre des finances si on élit
un gouvernement libéral
comme vous êtes l'absence de cet
argumentaire vis-à-vis la souveraineté
le voile il ya comme des pas des
silences mon sens on sent qu'il manque
un morceau oui on a un perdu nos repères
un peu au parti libéral dans les
dernières années puis en 2014 pour les
pillards avaient réussi à faire voter
les québécois pour les vraies affaires
c'était sur son thème va c'est voter
vraie vraie affaire on n'est pas très
loin mais il y avait eu coup d'éclat de
carlos l'état au puy martin coiteux puis
jacques ii ou qu'ils étaient des
banquiers des économies sont à respecter
la campagne avait commencé puis l'avait
dit ben ça sera une campagne sur
l'économie plutôt que sur la charte des
valeurs et le remporter son point entre
autres parce qu'il avait sept ce trio là
qu'ils pouvaient promener partout en
voyez je suis crédible sur cette
question-là pas actuellement parti
libéral bay manque encore 25 candidats
qui ont même pas été choisie peut-être
va-t-il y avoir des candidatures
économique prestigieuse mais c'est pas
lundi ce qu'elle est les clg déjà une
économie l'équipe économique très bonne
donc pour incarner ce sera plus
difficile que ce l'était à l'époque de
2014 alors pour le parti libéral pour
retrouver un nouvel enjeu et qu'on
trouve un enjeu la question économique
c'est ce qu'elle dit avec la question
essentielle est que le parti au pouvoir
dit parfait a tant besoin
on voit jouer dans le même film que vous
généralement c'est pas bon c'est un mot
ce fait les coûts y en avait aussi eu
un cadeau de pauline marois pierre karl
péladeau
when they are pas de porte
néanmoins une fois bien de me voir
partir d' avance mais quand le sujet est
retombé sur le référendum ça excite et
beaucoup de paix qu'il sait et ça fait
perdre l'élection aussi à madame marois
il y aura pas de cadeau comme ça cette
année véronique prince madame anglade
néanmoins là comme elle le dit bon mais
on remet les compteurs à zéro même si
c'est une image parce que les intentions
de vote restent là ne recommence pas à 0
n'empêche elle à la poche choix doit
faire une campagne plaidoyer à doit
plonger
on est tout à fait et pour terminer une
thèse sur le sujet d'économie et je
rappelle évidemment que dominique
anglade a été ministre de l'économie
alors elle va essayer vraiment de mettre
à l'avant scène cette caractéristique
leur dire qu'elles connaissent à quels
autres côtoyé milieu qu'elle a côtoyé
les gens d'affaires donc elle connaît
leurs besoins qu'elle connaît aussi les
besoins des québécois parce que sous
philippe couillard c'est ce qu'elle
faisait comme comme ministre mais en
même temps est-ce que les gens se
rappellent qu elle était ministre de
l'économie sous gouvernement couillard
parce que généralement c'est un
ministère où c'est connu du milieu des
affaires ce qu'on utilise entreprises
mais c'est pas très connu du grand
public ce pierre fitzgibbon est aussi
connue à la cac c'est peut-être
davantage en raison de ses frasques et
tout ce qui est sorti dans les médias
par rapport au commissaire à l'éthique
l'homme est généralement les ministres
de l'économie sont pas nécessairement
les plus flamboyants et donc elle part
avec un déficit peut-être au niveau de
ce que les gens connaissent d'elle
est-ce que les gens connaissent vraiment
dominique anglade parce qu'ils l'ont vu
critiquer le gouvernement legault comme
chef de l'opposition officielle et
sature un rôle ingrat le chef de
l'opposition officielle parce que jamais
contents et comme je disais on critique
est là aujourd'hui elle se présente tout
sourire ambiant par les compteurs à zéro
et son but baisse et se faire connaître
montrer son côté givré son côté plus
chaleureux en fait et c'est un
atmosphère un peu camp de vacances quand
lorsqu'on parle dans les autobus comme
sa campagne électorale une fébrilité
alors ça lui permet justement de montrer
qu'elle est bonne humeur et d'aller voir
ces militants tout à l'heure donc ça va
être sur son gros défi champagne patrice
c'est de se faire connaître ouais si on
fait exception de la des questions sur
la langue
de dés des questions sur les ports
religieux madame anglade en fait qui
était la présidente du parti de monsieur
legault le mois elle était candidate de
la cac à laval à l'époque bon elle a
changé justement est-ce que seuls 10 est
inconfortable avec tout le volet
identité de la caq mais son drame en
quelque part c'est que beaucoup de ces
politiques ressemble à ce que le
gouvernement fait
oui puis aussi sa grande difficulté
c'est que le parti libéral se retrouve à
ménager la chèvre et le chou là parce
qu'on veut conserver le vote anglophone
parce que c'est la base mais en même
temps le vote francophone il ya une
cascade l'on peut pas continuer de le
perdre comme ça donc on se retrouve
toujours au parti libéral me dit le
stratège et un peu entre deux chaises et
là je pense que l est sur le point de
partir effectivement la donne autour de
ces questions il non je ne manquais pas
inquiété pour compléter la tu fais ta
haine non non c'est ce qu'annonce quand
je veux courir en arrière le jeu court à
subir tous
à l'arrêt
alors est ce que je sais c'est que sur
les enjeux identitaires c'est sûr que il
ya eu un glissement qui s'est fait là
avec la réforme la loi 101 il ya eu elle
s'est mis à dos beaucoup de libéraux
beaucoup d'anglophones beaucoup de gens
qui étaient dans sa base la question sur
la laïcité aussi mais elle ne pourra pas
éluder ces sujets là ces questions là
vont revenir systématiquement campagne
électorale comme c'est le cas pour
chacune des campagnes
même si françois legault va peut-être
moins en parler de ce qu'on s'attendait
elle va devoir répondre là dessus on
verra sa position va évoluer par rapport
aux dernières années
véronique prince on va se parler tous
les jours on va se reparler même si la
fin de l'émission vous je vous suivez la
chef libéral dans cette première partie
de campagne merci beaucoup sébastien
elle va à la fontaine je veux quand même
qu'on le montre visuellement le dit
circonscriptions qu'on ne veut pas
perdre on est dans cette logique là dans
l'est de montréal 2 dont lille dans le
nord est de montréal et c'est
symptomatique de l'état d'esprit des
libéraux probablement qui veulent sauver
les circonscriptions alors la fontaine
c'est ici marc tanguay et le député il a
gagné par 9000 voix 9000 voix aux
dernières élections donc en principe une
circonscription sûre pour le parti
libéral mais je répète ma phrase dis moi
où tu vois et je te dirai ce que tu veux
faire silva dans la fontaine pour lancer
sa campagne électorale aujourd'hui parce
que probablement elles sont le besoin
d'y aller et ce sera intéressant de voir
où dominique anglade vol sur l'est de
montréal parce que en général l'île de
montréal c'est sans histoire l'ouest
vote libéral il y avait des du parti
québécois dans le secteur un peu plus à
l'est parfois c'est québec solidaire qui
prend d'expansion la caq espère que la
vague bleue va traverser le fleuve ici
et notamment dans la circonscription de
services et à ses 1 800 tonnes c'est la
circonscription de dominique anglade est
ce qu'elle va passer du temps dans cette
circonscription la sq elle va passer du
temps aussi dans verdun qui est une
autre circonscription sur laquelle à la
fois québec solidaire et la coalition a
mené à québec ont les yeux donc deux
circonscriptions surveiller même marque
est ici avec enrico ciccone qui a au
passage très bien fait la transition
entre joueurs de hockey analystes de
sport s apprécié monsieur cecconi
représenterait à la chine enfin à
marquette donc le bon débuté pour le
parti libéral mais ce qu'il faut noter
avec le parti libéral c'est qu'ils sont
pas en mode expansion il pense pas aller
pour pouvoir aller chercher beaucoup
d'eau de nouvelles circonscriptions ils
sont en mode on sauve les meubles on
essaie de garder ce qu'on a les yeux qui
compte un mot avant de passer à mémère
sur laval parce que là on craint chez
les libéraux d'en perdre 4 peut-être oui
et la balle c'est intéressant parce que
il ya beaucoup de sommeil il ya des
circuits et plusieurs circonscriptions à
la vas y en a une seule qui ait de la
coalition avenir québec mais à peu près
toutes les autres circonscriptions sont
en jeu et sont dans le viseur de la cac
fabre je passe par dessus je me dis pas
ce que je vais vous en parlait dans un
instant laval des rapides sao paulo a
gagné par quelques vous dizaines de voix
aux dernières élections pour le parti
libéral donc c'est dans la mire de la
carec vimont emile elle aussi chaud mais
des séquences culture particulière parce
que le gouallec a été élu dans cette
circonscription en 2018 il n'est plus le
député du parti libéral il est député
indépendant il se représente pas aux
élections les libéraux pensent qu'ils
ont une solide base en jeu mais des donc
ça pourrait être celle dans laquelle ils
peuvent conserver des acquis mais pour
toutes les autres la colle sur mer
québec pense qu'elle peut faire des
gains à la très bien régis manon luc
les défis de dominique anglade j'ai
commencé avec vos régimes
de 2,2 sauver le plus de commentaires et
de costello puissiez pas de problème ces
parcelles libres à tout le monde le dit
c'est devenu dans les clubs dernier zone
est une espèce de poules pas de tête une
sortie des loges idéologiquement couple
a perdu ceci dit alors c'est bien sûr
que de confronter la 4 sur l'économie
s'est passé mais oh ouais
la chef madame arrêt glad elle est à
l'aise dans cette thématique là et
pendant qu'un benfeld et alain zosso
mode jeu donc je dois donc femmes ceci
dit sur le terrain je suis sur le
terrain je suis convaincu que les caddys
de libéraux ne ferons pas l'économie
de tâter faire croire aux gens que
d'hommes sont françois lacoste et
séparatistes fantôme je pense qu'ils
vont le faire bien en masse et
finalement moi j'étais mené par delà de
jouer la carte vivent sans parce
qu'elles vivent en france et à satoshi
ya tel salaire assemblage ça comme l'air
aussi des trucs du revenu québec si
pauvrement kotchman manon des films
madame anglade dalle moi je trouve
qu'ils étaient d'accord avec régis cette
fois l'or effectivement je pense que
c'est sauver mêmes mais c'est de voir
comment ça va se traduire mais je vous
dis dans certains comtés on verra
comment ça va se traduire le jour du
monde est commun avec le taux
participation il pourrait avoir des
petites surprises mais on verra et je
pense que effectivement faut sauver les
meubles l'udc
mais moi je trouve que maman hagglund
elle a souvent débat d'idées apparaître
les ballons les chars au milieu de
terrain parce que là son économie par
exemple
c'est crucial legault s'est mis le pied
dans la bouche à l'évocation de
l'inflation avec la ligne entre delle
l'environnement qui sont les 3 f est
contre-productif de demander les
majeures c'est trois robes aux immenses
enjeux il laissa jamais lu ming est là
elle nous dit que effectivement il va
falloir ciblé cela mais en disant non
j'ai eu la campagne c'est l'économie
s'est pas l'économie c'est les est fier
de l'économie il la récupère tyrrell
avec une moyenne de mercy le gouverneur
tir avec le morceau qui trouvent que
leurs actes et en partie pourquoi quand
elles se présentent vivre et l'idée trop
général
pendant trop générale vous dites oui
trop générale passe pas si le parti a
pas une tradition de critiquer
d'opposition sont intéressants de cannes
d'économie et elle doit les ventes y
7,30 ce mot là et elle y arrive
merci beaucoup
région de québec
habituellement on parle beaucoup moins
de la région de montréal parce que vous
l'avez dit plusieurs fois depuis ce
matin sébastien les jeux sont pas mal
fait région de québec
l'intérêt
c'est de voir est ce que le parti
conservateur va ou non prendre racine
dans une circonscription capitale
nationale donc beaucoup de bleu de la
coalition a mené à québec il ya
certaines circonscriptions
justice'' centre-ville de québec qui
n'ont pas voté pour la coalition and if
quebec mais encore une fois fait
attention ici à la couleur que je vous
montre parce que la circonscription ici
de jean talon a été prise par la
coalition a mené qu'avec bref il reste
deux circonscriptions défendu par québec
solidaire circonscription de jean lesage
avec seuls les nantis catherine dorion
avait été élu dans tâches où il y aurait
une belle lutte avec le parti québécois
notamment dans notre choix ce sera
intéressant à suivre mais celle qu'on va
particulièrement surveillé ses chevaux
ses conscription caquistes sylvain
lévesque a été élu député de la cac
c'est là que éric duhaime ce présent
pourquoi chauveau
pourquoi pas ailleurs parce que chauveau
un fonds à des kystes la plateforme
électorale des conservateurs et
d'inspiration adéquiste a prononcé comme
ça je devais m'en passe ont été
conseillés de mario dumont à une
certaine époque avec la dq et star wars
et ne mettrait pas coucy et de jeunes et
beaucoup aux bleus mais bien la pointe
et donc dans chauveau il ya eu des
députés de la dq qui ont été un député
de la dq qui a été élu gérard deltell
notamment calé chef de la dae qu à un
certain moment donc il ya un terreau
fertile semble-t-il en fait c'est le
calcul qu'on fait pour le
parti conservateur du québec je vous
amène dans chaudière-appalaches parce
que là aussi donc rive sud de québec la
colle le pass conservateur a divisé ses
bleus 4 il ya cette circonscription
conférence sur la rive sud de québec
cette circonscription cac est malade
dans beauce-nord le parti conservateur
pense avoir des désespoirs dabo sud
aussi les deux circonscriptions donc de
chaudière appalaches qu'on va surveiller
mais peut-être bellechasse aussi un peu
plus à l'est mais c'est là qu'ils
pourraient faire des gains peut-être
mais ça il faudrait que l'eau de la
piscine montrent pas mal pour lui parce
qu'à 14 15
oui c'est si c'est très concentré oui
mais pour aller chercher les deux seuls
besoins de la beauce faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose dans les deux prochaines
semaines 14 15 et concentrés dans la
grande région qui va cesser son 114,15
est dopé par la région de québec je vous
dis pas que ça va se faire embaucher de
beauce-nord ils ont passé ils sont
passés avec des grosses majorité les les
capistes dans ces circonscriptions là
mais qui sait peut-être que enfin on
fait le calcul au parti conservateur qui
ont pu s'enraciner dans ces
circonstances nation beauceronne oui
voilà ouais ils vont voter différemment
avec ces derniers a donné m
donnez
le jury délibère là-dessus cerveau qui
va peut-être venir au parti las une
autre émission qu'on ouvre c'est dans
deux semaines c'est le congrès
conservateur maxime bernier qui peut
être viendrez au parti conservateur
dirigé par monsieur poilievre
très sérieusement c'est pierre poilievre
veut avoir une révolte de la section de
son caucus qui ne l'est pas au
leadership c'est la chose à faire
là on pousse le bouchon ok mais alors
que l'appui de maxime bernier éric
duhaime aurait fait une différence mais
deux fois les électeurs de beauce ont
dit non à maxime bernier il ne peut plus
se faire élire dans ce qui était un
château fort familiale alors ça plus de
poids que ça avait et au fédéral éric
duhaime ne vote pas parti populaire du
canada donc botte pas maxime bernier
votre conservateur très bien ghislaine
buissière à québec vous êtes allés à la
rencontre des électeurs
oui patrice est pas pour rien là qu'on
est devant le pont de québec pour la
porte ce matin parce que la mobilité
c'est un des grands enjeux à québec on
peut pas se le cacher la cacp auteurs
pensent à un tunnel les libéraux veulent
un tramway pour se rendre à lévis q
est-ce ne veut pas de 3e et lyon aussi
et les conservateurs temps d'un deuxième
pont le pour passer de l'île d'orléans
vers la rive sud de québec donc
plusieurs propositions sur la table et
l'enjeu aussi de la qualité de l'air
patrice dans le centre ville de québec
on sait la caq à rehausser les seuils
pour le nikkei et ça ça fait beaucoup
jaser eu beaucoup d'oppositions donc la
mobilité l'environnement deux thèmes
importants québec je vous laisse écouter
quelques électeurs
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
troisième bien
côté face à ces choses qui me sera plus
incarné le tramway moi je le veux
c'est là que je franchis un peu contre
la cac qui veut avoir le troisième lien
et puis moi je le veux pas alors ça
c'est un gros
en terme général la mobilité
je trouve que c'est important en
environnement aussi qui était classé
comme étant un sujet puisque sommes de
moins en moins light ou du moins prendre
un aspect plus défensif de
la feuille de route faits par les
gouvernements passés
je vois donc elle surveillée à sébastien
a parlé chauveau évidemment avec le chef
conservateur
aussi jean lassalle jean lesage se
zanetti le le candidat québec solidaire
qui a gagné par seulement 699 voile dans
cette circonscription la dernière fois
deux circonscriptions à surveiller et
bossu de beauce nord du côté de la rive
sud du fleuve matrix merci beaucoup
c'est une journée magnifique ghislaine
devant l'image de ce fleuve majestueux
derrière - dupont québec qui fait
l'objet de chicane d'ailleurs je vais
aller voir je peux pas faire autrement
qu'ils allaient voir régissent la
merci beaucoup ghislaine les bonnes
campagnes à vous alors régis troisième
lien pont de québec
j'étais en forme jeudi dernier la vous
étiez catégorique est-ce que tu as
raconté à tout le québec comment cet
enjeu là va jouer d'abord dans les gens
de québec et partout ailleurs
oui on peut pas faire une investir de 10
milliards de dollars de l'heure dans un
duel à québec c'est tout d'abord
bon sur moscou surtout que si vous aimez
bouger d'accord ce que tu es tellement
cette semaine cette espèce de folie des
sur le port de québec ça a pris des
années je vais demander pendant
tellement longtemps qu'on puisse que le
fédéral puisse prendre la décision de
devenir de posséder le pont de québec et
de cent ans avec le cn sur son commencé
sa mise à niveau pour les prochaines
décennies alors
c'est fait les gens sont en attente
mais pour des raisons de cynisme
politique le grunge québec de voeux pour
ajouter les quelques millions
nécessaires année alors qu'ils ont des
budgets
d'investissements d'infrastructures
prévus 2 milliards de dollars alors moi
je pense que ça peut faire mal à la caq
à québec jeudi d'ilakaka québec à ils
ont très peur de monsieur duhaime me
suis dit à mes parents du nord il est
vrai en arrière comme vous le dire kg ne
pas monter mais je peux vous dire que
les députés aient québec
particulièrement suc sont en périphérie
sur la ville sud et moi je suis un petit
peu pour madame d'iran
que s'ils dérangent mais la chose et si
monsieur duhaime avait le choix il ne
refuserait pas un show où il serait
dangereux de la chaudière et je pense
que si elle ment à laquelle on demande
aux députés que c'est 2-2 ne le déclare
à la dernière minute alors ça sera pas
simple puisque vous dire que vous
sérieux
les chiffres à québec rrq aussi sont
dopés par la forte concentration du vote
de québec solidaire dans taschereau et
aussi les moines ou alors ce que je vous
dirais c'est que
probablement généralement à part le
centre-ville de québec
le parti conservateur est plus fort
qu'on le pense bon c'est à moi mais là
ils veulent pas de troisième ligne sa
série veulent oui à dieu elle veut un
pont faire un autre à branchement de
pont de l'île vers le sud ça vous pensez
que il va avoir il pourrait gagner des
appuis dans le sud exigé
propriété lijun de ce même pire des fois
l'homme et pts et ceci pour julien saint
geours paulette sus du mv partie du
commun dire de l'adn des radios de
québec des radios toxiques il les avait
clairement
aux émissions de clients alors lui ça va
aussi
les jeunes qui sont éclairés les gens
que liberté
liberté ce serait exactement qu'est très
bien luc votre vision de ce qui va se
passer dans la grande région de québec
troisième lien je vous donne carte
blanche
mais le troisième et demande pas qu'on
avec monsieur labeaume c'est une hérésie
la construction d'une cathédrale dans un
désert mon père
et l'achalandage
quand on compare avec les autres
ouvrages travers le monde mais même
jusqu'au québec par exemple le pont de
champion le court chante mais à montréal
il ya même pas photo la sideci un
achalandage et fini mon plus grand quand
on dit qu'on veut faire le nid entre du
centre ville on imagine par exemple
entre
le new jersey punis alors quoi entre
autres
ville de la coiffe noire américaine les
nids mais et je n'ai rien contre evil ce
n'est pas une ville d'un million
d'habitants qui nécessite un pense par
l'eau comme un double tunnel
personnes au québec qui en connaissant
ce domaine lors que vous appuyer ce
projet là
pour moi ça me dépasse 100 boutiques
mart et je pense que monsieur labeaume a
raison de dire que la seule raison pour
laquelle ce doute sur plein temps sont
établies à cause surtout québec il n'y a
pas de couy d'universitaires
le peuple les sondages 60 % pour la
région de québec
web et à villareal seule la pizza les
vois que ça va changer un peu un camp
mais quand bien même les gens de bosses
de bourse de beauce-nord sont d'accord
ça change pas de vie
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les gens
des villes mais c'est pas de betteraves
voile c'est un engagement avec laquelle
le premier ministre et prier parce
qu'ils en avaient besoin pour gagner la
veille en madame annoncé est ce que ça
et ça ça résonne sap et recolle ailleurs
d'un région québec ça ou c'est vraiment
un débat qu'on entend beaucoup à
montréal et à québec
je
sais mais c'est surtout au québec à
moyen mais pour comprendre que ça va
être certainement intéressés à suivre la
campagne québec la rive sud ou sud
québec jusqu'au bois saint laurent nous
verrons je suppose se doucher d'envoi
n'est pas la rive sud mais c'est sûr que
pour québec je pense que les jeux sont
faits pour vivre la suite des choses
très bien de ravages des quelque chose
du moins l'ont rapidement
sa touche tous les québécois parce que
le port des lecques luc de poule même
s'il est élu à l'opinel même s'il est
totalement sous-estimé il représente
warsan pour ça de la correction de tous
les difficiles d'euros de contrats
d'entretien de maintenance mais routes
du québec tout le québec va souffrir et
on met plus 10 milliards dans un pont à
québec
c'est du délire
cet enfer vous emballez là c'est parfait
très bien mais il ya beaucoup de gens
sébastienne en région de québec qu'ils
veulent et monsieur legault je ne
jugerai pas l'expression
de l'udc et de
régis mais monsieur legault l'a promis
on parle pour qui va reculer ou
peut-être peut-être que le fait que le
fédéral ne finance pas ré une petite
porte de sortie les projets de 10
milliards de dhs affirmé des années à
l'avancé qu'ils vont se concrétiser
c'est un peu regardé dans une boule de
cristal essayer de prévoir l'avenir donc
il ya tellement de choses qui peuvent
survenir il ya des gens qui pensaient
québec monsieur legault faire l'élection
sur le troisième vient peut-être la
prochaine sera fait aussi son troisième
ligne sans jamais qu'on voit la lumière
au bout de shell à un moment donné donc
qu'ils fassent plusieurs élections là
dessus quand même comme la ligne bleue
sans jamais que le projet se passe mais
dans le discours public en ce moment
on maintient fermement qu'on veut faire
le troisième lien l'avenir nous dira si
on fait ça se passe très bien un petit
mot là dessus ou sur les
circonscriptions de la rive sud dont
parle veulent troisième ligne je les vis
chutes de la chaudière les bosses de
bellechasse
ont dit pour françois legault étonné
mais françois legault a besoin de ces
circonscriptions là il va pas changer du
secours en cours de route c'est les
endroits où le parti conservateur d'éric
duhaime est le plus fort donc si van tu
helmand une façon de sortir de ce projet
là certains disent l'argent du fédéral
peut-être les études environnementales
aussi je parierais pas ma chemise quel
bac vous trouvez que c'est une bonne
idée de creuser un tunnel dans le fleuve
saint laurent éventuellement il est
peut-être des portes de sortie mais
cette campagne sinon troisième lyon il
va puis on dit qu'on va le construire le
jeu le prochain discours là dessus et
peut-être davantage de chiffres de
donner à indret ou des bols passé ce
lundi plus de gens qui en parlent comme
on vient d'entendre qu un espèce de
rapport risque gains et oui pour cette
élection si on garde ses sièges là en
faisant ça mais ça coûte ça commence à
coûter des votes sur la marque de
commerce déjà pas forte forte en
environnement par exemple ou même en
gestion de fonds publics et de gestion
des routes et transports que de la
coalition menées avec des courbes et du
fils sont nés dans la gestion des
finances publiques ou si beaucoup
là-dedans
mauricie
tout à l'heure je disais que éric
duhaime lui veut
des visées sur la mauricie ce une région
alors on s'attend quoi mais pas beaucoup
d'histoires en mauricie voyez la carte
en 2018 ces bleus de la coalition à
venir à québec sauf que vous parlez des
rituels je qualifierais de fantasmes
d'éric duhaime de pouvoir faire une
percée en mauricie et au centre du
québec la mauricie a déjà élu à trois
rivières un député de la dq c'était
sébastien proulx à l'époque et dans le
centre du québec donc de l'autre côté du
fleuve à drummondville notamment il y
avait déjà eu un député delà de la dq
sébastien chine berger qui est
aujourd'hui député de de la coalition en
irak avec d'opium peut-être une les
idées sont capables de percolé les idées
conservatrices dans cette région là donc
en principe c'est le portrait devrait
rester relativement le même mais le
parti conservateur espère peut-être fait
une percée mêmes phrases dites moi où
vous allez je vous dirai ce que vous
essayez de faire éric duhaime a lancé sa
plateforme électorale à drummondville
donc est ce que c'est un signe que il à
des expirations pour cette région là et
dernière des choses on parlait de
l'appui au parti conservateur à 14% des
intentions de vote le parti conservateur
pense que ses sympathisants sont
discrets dans les dans les sondages et
que donc ça pourrait être plus que
quatre ans pensons évidemment on est un
peu dans le spin ici il faut faire
attention mais c'est ils ont de la
difficulté à eux mêmes à
mesurer l'appui qu'ils ont en ce moment
véritablement dans les sondages avec le
dopage qu'il ya évidemment des
intentions de vote dans la région québec
mais pour l'ensemble du québec
voyez l'image
magnifique de ces chutes c'est là c'est
de là que le candidat françois legault
premier ministre va faire son point de
tenir son point de presse
ça les lieux depuis
je parlais tout à l'heure de stock world
i et d'eric des matrix accorder ce
crédit est un maître de la mise en scène
politique ne sera plus à développer ce
aussi d'avoir la simplification du
message politique promettent cinq choses
pour 8.95 chose revenir là dessus merci
ce poilievre est comme ça c'est le même
discours qui refait
ville après ville est alors j'étais
votre attention sur quand même ce décor
majestueux attention stock but quand
même deux choses la première cette
aventure de motomarines
sortait ans et l'est et il voulait
expliquer que le parlement devrait pas
siéger le vendredi vice et la deuxième
allait faire un point de presse au bord
d'une rivière niagara pour pas le nommer
et pour être capable de répondre à une
question dans quel sens et ce qu'elle
coule oui non j'ai pas dit qu'il y avait
eu le succès qu'il
y avait une volonté de planter des
décors pee wee les labs
implantée dans le décor il a regardé
quand même sébastien cessez-le-feu c'est
la région québec puis dans la région
québec la coalition est venu à québec
est bien implanté donc on veut faire on
espère pouvoir faire des gains on espère
pouvoir aussi
consolider les acquis s'assurer de ces
ondes l'argent québec on parle quand
françois legault pain il parle beaucoup
du parti conservateur on sent que c'est
le chicotte on sent que ça de travail et
donc c'est important pour lui de lancer
à québec sa campagne et on retourne plus
au sud on remonte le fleuve raphaël
droit vous êtes à trois rivières et vous
avez parlé à des électeurs
ouais tout à fait qu'ils vont suivre
cette campagne électorale ici en
mauricie ya plusieurs gens les enjeux
notamment ici à trois-rivières tout ce
qui est crise du logement le taux
d'inoccupation des loyers qui est à
moins de 1% dans la ville il est
inhérent ce également les ressources qui
aide ces personnes sans logement nous le
disent elles sont débordés depuis des
mois il ya également tout ce qui est
l'environnement on est bon sur le bord
du fleuve la protection des berges c'est
très important ici en moxxi d'ailleurs
c'est à trois rivières que le ministre
le premier ministre sortant françois
legault a fait cette annonce de plan
bleu ans pour la protection des cours
d'eau partout dans la province il ya eu
des glissements terrain récemment des
inondations aussi dans les dernières
années et les soins aux aînés également
parce que la mauricie c'est une des plus
vieilles régions du québec donc ça
inquiète les gens ont pu écouter
quelques électeurs
ici malheureusement j'habite pas dans ce
coin de pays mais je peux simplement
dire qu'effectivement au niveau de
l'éducation et de la santé on a besoin
d'être partout au québec et c'est
essentiel mais bon l'emploi les jeunes
qui sont qui ont disparu on cherche à
coupler restera les hôtels on cherche
des employés c'est un petit peu en ce
moment où sont passés tout le monde
c'est à dire qu'on prenne soin de nos
sans abri puis de ceux qui sont
désemparés dans la vie ça c'est une
priorité ça aussi je crois que aux
parois des shoots police aussi un moyen
voire d'un mois de débats dans tous les
sens et puis je pense que ça va être une
campagne intéressant
il ya également la fameuse vallée de la
batterie qui devraient être annoncées
dans la région ça aussi ça préoccupe
dans la région tout ce qui est
industries de technologies vertes donc
on va suivre ça également on verra un
peu le portrait parce que quatre
candidats sortants de la cac en mauricie
qui se représente donc on verra un peu
de quazar l'air
je le répète pour vous' images
merveilleuses ce dimanche est un des
plus beaux dimanches du mois d'août avec
le ciel typique du mois d'août - du
taiseux bleus
alors merci beaucoup et on va se
reparler merci bonne campagne à vous
et je vais aller en outaouais parce que
là autrefois n'avait pas vraiment
d'histoire en août hawaï et commence à
en avoir en 2018 le parti libéral a
perdu des circonscriptions guêtres sinon
un troll catherine maurras bonjour
bonjour
bonjour alors là à surveiller la paix on
le verra avec sébastien après il ya des
circonscriptions qu'on surveille hall
notamment
wake était une forteresse libérale
écouter la dernière fois où un élu non
libéral a été choisie elle est bien faut
remonter à
1976 pour le retrouver alors la députée
sortante actuelle maryse gaudreault va
essayer de briguer un cinquième mandat
elle est là depuis 2008 donc la cac pour
la déloger mis sur une nouvelle venue en
politique c'est une femme qui est bien
connu sur nos autres parce que c'est un
syndicaliste elle s'appelle suzanne
tremblay elle a été longtemps président
du syndicat des enseignants de
l'outaouais il y aura aussi dans le
pontiac andré fortin le libéral va
chercher un troisième mandat hélas la
caq lui oppose également une nouvelle
venue qui s'appelle korine côté
qu'annuelle est les fonctionnaires dans
la fonction publique fédérale enfin pour
les enjeux je pense que je surprendrait
personne en vous disant qu'on a des
grands besoins en matière de santé
d'éducation ce qui est spécial avec
l'utah ouest c'est la proximité de
l'ontario de comptes matière de santé
parce qu'il ya des meilleures conditions
travaillent en ontario ça fait une fuite
des travailleurs et se fait des
situations comme par exemple à l'hôpital
du pontiac hunger service d'obstétrique
est fermé depuis un an et demi parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à trouver du
personnel alors la cac était en mode
séduction les dernières années on a
promis un nouvel hôpital de 600 lits on
a aussi promis d'aider des primes aux
infirmières qui viennent s'installer en
outaouais mais tous ces projets là en
sont encore à leurs premiers
balbutiements l'on veut sur ma mise et
la tuque beaucoup en campagne enfin en
matière de logement il ya une forte
pression qui viennent ottawa notre
mairesse le d'hier gatineau est le
logement d'abord da abordable de tahoua
ce qu'on peut trouver l'autre côté de la
rivière pour 1800 $ et bien on trouve
facilement ici pour 1000 1200 $ par mois
alors que le forte migration bref
logement santé services sociaux tous d
des enjeux qu'on va surveiller quand on
n'est pas très concret sur les électeurs
drôle que tu avais une grosse que
tellement de rumeurs je suis pour
remettre une carte et nancy n'ont que la
priorité c'est définitivement la jument
parce que sa patte allure le prix et
commencent que le prix des logements
martin les maisons et puis des logements
louis aussi faire ça je m y habiter si
l'économie est belle et sa remorque
tout va bien la vie est trop chère
l'éducation notre chère elle et les
transformations sont trop chers toutes
sont trop chaudes
savez je n'ai vu un petit avant goût du
risque aussi oui on risque aussi
beaucoup de parler de la loi 96 alors
qu'une forte proportion de population
anglophone dans la région merci beaucoup
à très bientôt
c'est facile en 2018 la cac avait donc
grignoter des circonscriptions aux
libéraux dans l'outaouais
l'outaouais avait l'habitude d'être
rouge du béal cinq circonscriptions en
outaouais tout libéral historiquement
mais en effet vous avez vu la cac perd
une percée dans papineau dans gatineau
petite circonscription ici également
qu'ils échappent l'eau est juste à côté
elle qui est en rose dur avoir
probablement sur ma carte mais je vous
prie ma parole elle est en rouge maryse
gaudreault qui est une des pet est
apprécié et vice président de
l'assemblée nationale non plus notamment
pourraient être en danger la cac en tout
cas des visées sur cette circonscription
je termine en vous parlant pontiac avec
henri fontaine je pense que pas de
problème pour monsieur fortin d'être élu
là vous voyez la progression
graduelle de la coalition avenir québec
dans cette région et quand toute la
logique d'être à l'offensive on a
demandé à madame anglais à tout à
l'heure une journée latvala france et
vous allez défensive ira-t-elle à
gatineau tenter de reprendre cette
circonscription la au port est ce qu on
va plutôt se concentrer voilà des
questions intéressant
plutôt mourir c'est l'exemple type de ce
qui arrive quand on perd la colle du
fédéralisme et de la souveraineté parce
qu'il ya une foule d'électeurs dans
gatineau dans un rôle un peu moins un
pontiac parce qu'on commence à
s'éloigner qui sont des fonctionnaires
fédéraux
et donc quand la lutte classique pq
libéraux se présente c'est difficile
d'imaginer qu'on va voter pour vous
faire disparaître la fonction publique
fédérale malgré que vous vous rappelez
les promesses de jacques parizeau en 95
s'est bougé des votes en faisant ses
premiers cela il y en avait perdu dans
la région de québec fonction publique
québécoise donc là il n'y a plus rien
qui au quotidien ses électeurs d'aller
voir la cac parce que ils sont plus de
vendre un danger réel et imminent dans
leur esprit c'est à dire le parti
québécois est en effet non alors il ça
change toute cette région là comme vous
dites essentiellement voyez des images
on commence à bouger autour
de l'endroit où nous donnera son premier
point de presse de la campagne françois
legault avec ses dents quelques minutes
on va aller au saguenay on a le temps je
crois ont valu au saguenay fait les plus
heureux tout à l'heure on en parlait du
saguenay le la cac est à l'offensive
également on va aller chercher la
circonscription qu'on a pas
jean-pierre à parce qu'il ya cinq
circonscriptions saguenay lac-saint-jean
quatre d'entre elles ont détenu par la
coalition avenir québec la cinquième
c'est le parti québécois et sylvain
gaudreault qui sont présents à
jean-pierre mais on se rappelle que
sylvain gaudreault avait annoncé qu'il
ne se représentait pas pour ces
élections alors ce sera l'un des enjeux
assurément pour cette prochaine élection
la circonscription de jean pièces non
s'est elle aussi a parlé avec plusieurs
personnes de leur offrir des grands
thèmes l'équipe on surveille bien
évidemment la santé l'éducation
l'environnement ya même une dame là
rien qui m'a parlé des dépendances mais
qui a rapidement ajouté que ce n'était
pas du tout sa priorité pour cette
élection si ce qui revient sûrement
c'est l'économie à plusieurs enjeux ici
qui sont reliés à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre comme partout ailleurs le
vieillissement de la population des
sujets intimement liés c'est qu'on a
remarqué que dans les vingt dernières
années au saguenay-lac-saint-jean la
proportion des 65 ans et plus a doublé
alors ça a un effet bien évidemment sur
le reste de la société ensuite
l'industrie forestière un public dans la
région niveau économique qu'au mans a
balancé la protection de l'habitat du
caribou forestier
les exploitations forestières ça sera
l'une des grandes questions et peut-être
aussi troisièmement verra-t-on le retour
du projet de gnl québec parce que y'a le
parti conservateur du québec qui veut
remettre de l'avant le projet de gnl
québec même s'il a été refusée autant
par québec que par ottawa alors
plusieurs choses à surveiller beaucoup
autour de l'économie je sens que
quelques personnes avant de dire un peu
plus tôt
surtout l'eau la sarthe mais à mon âge
c'est sûr là mais c'est la santé et
l'éducation je trouve que nos jeunes ont
besoin d'un bon coup de pouce c'est pour
mieux mettre la santé
nous aimons l'éducation par l'économie
soit pendant le solo pour le reste
l'euro il faut d'ouvragé la santé la
santé la santé pour une raison non parce
que c'est épouvantable la santé partout
des hôpitaux des siens chez seul départ
tout l'environnement et d'économie ont
cédé impôts main je trouve qu'on paye
cher des épopées c'est sûr que
l'environnement aussi mais je trouve
qu'on paie cher d'impôt pompey on paye
partout
c'est important de mentionner badri ce
qui reste du travail à faire surtout
pour le parti libéral du québec cinq
circonscriptions dans la région
seulement deux candidats confirmés les
deux à roberval et au lac saint jean
pour donc pour du beurre chicoutimi
jonquière toujours aucun candidat qui
ont été présentés alors ça reste à
surveiller la quel moment il y aura ces
annonces dans les semaines à venir merci
beaucoup à le souligner à dominique
anglade tout à l'heure on lui a demandé
pourquoi faisait pas beau 125 candidats
de candidats et 10 est arrivé dans les
prochains jours sébastien des fois on a
un gars des grosses vedettes mais là
c'est on peut comprendre que dans
certains endroits c'est plus difficile
je pense que le scénario des grosses
vedettes et écarté pour lui sané
lac-saint-jean donc on fait le tour
alors ne vous laissez pas distraire par
c'est la grosse circonscription en rouge
c'est celle que philippe couillard avait
rapporté roberval en 2018 monsieur
couillard a quittés et depuis c'est
devenu une circonscription de la cac pas
très bon en dessin dont je vais vous
écrire simplement la met en rouge offre
chinoise la circonscription à surveiller
c'est celle ci ici jean pierre la
circonscription de sylvain gaudreault du
parti québécois elle est en bleu donc
parce que le parti québécois l'avait
emporté il ne se représente pas monsieur
gaudreault la coalition a mené québec
pense avoir des chances d'aller chercher
cette circonscription d'ailleurs pas
innocent pas anodin que françois legault
après sa conférence de presse à lachute
moment s'ils prennent la route de la
réserve faunique des laurentides pour
aller à jonquière est lancée avec ses
militants la campagne électorale danjean
qui est donc ce sera intéressant de
suivre jean pierre a part ça le fait que
le parti libéral est pas beaucoup de
candidats dans cette circonscription
c'est quand même symptomatique des
problèmes de recrutement qu'ils ont en
ce moment alors qu'ils ont déjà eu des
ministres des députés et au 5 mai 2011
en plus quand minutes
couillard robert tous a été aspirée par
la cac ce grand mouvement qui est les
crocs 1 s'est un peu on va dire ça comme
ça anglade donc en attente mesdames et
messieurs du point de presse premier de
la campagne de monsieur legault on en
parlait tout à l'heure ce qui était avec
nous c'est une tradition tous les chefs
par madame marois avait essayé une autre
façon de faire un
2014 n'avait pas très bien fonctionné la
presse atteint à ce que et surtout de la
part du premier ministre pourquoi vous
utile que les québécois continuent pour
reprendre le slogan de campagne avec lui
son plaidoyer entendre les mots on verra
ça va être intéressant de voir qu est-ce
qu il choisi comme sujet qu'est ce qui
laisse de côté et d'un cas de madame
marois ce qui était particulier c'est
que en 2013 son gouvernement avait fait
adopter une loi sur les élections à date
fixe donc le principe avait été légalisé
elle était évidemment la tête d'un
gouvernement minoritaire et le décidé
donc de déclencher ces élections là en
2014 avant la fin de son mandat que les
québécois lui avait donné et ne pas
expliquer comment ça se fait que en
ayant adopté une loi pour les élections
à date fixe il déclenche quand même des
élections avant la fin de son mandat on
comprendre qu'il avait le droit parce
qu'elle était à la tête d'un
gouvernement minoritaire mais il y avait
eu ce décalage dans la façon de lancer
la campagne pour madame et à la fin de
la campagne avait encore des candidats
péquistes qui se faisait demander
pourquoi il ya une campagne électorale
cinq semaines plus tard en face aux
insultes rude aux
premières questions
à tous à peu près monsieur trudeau ce
puisque c'est votre dernière campagne
monsieur legault va se la faire poser ce
salon classique lui n'exclut plus parce
qu'il avait fait l'erreur roman n'est de
dire l'erreur tactique de dire oui deux
mandats je serai ces vieux après mais il
l'a refait plus longs les il évoque même
un troisième mandat meilleur des
sceptiques dans la surface et donne
guère oui parce que sinon la course à la
direction
alors vous attendez à quoi on l'a vu
alec et chantal on l'a vu tout à l'heure
humble éducation santé le coût de la vie
on vous attendez à quoi dans le message
de monsieur legault québécois dans quel
que soit l'événement que le premier
ministre dit on va parler de tout ce qui
était important qu'il nomme à peu près
tous la liste d'épicerie de l'éducation
à l'immigration en passant par la santé
et l'économie bon je pense qu'en réalité
je suis plus ou moins d'accord avec que
régis laborde notre ami de l'heure qui
disait qu'il va taper sur le coup le
cloud de l'identité de l'immigration je
ne pense pas qu'il va faire ça
personnellement je pense qu'il a très
bien campés dans l'esprit des gens où
ils se situent sur ces questions là et
de monsieur si un événement fortuite
campagne si ça brasse auch maroc semble
si le fédéral intervient dans une clause
dans une cause particulière devant les
tribunaux il va pas se priver il va pas
se priver de faire campagne sur
l'identité masse qui va mettre
volontairement de l'avant ces thèmes là
je pense qu il le fait tout le travail
avec la louisianisation du québec l
époque c'est bien campés alors envoyé
sur l'économie la santé un peu
d'environnement je pense qu'il va rester
autour de ces fameux le coût de la vie
humaine comme un mec je vais essayer de
dire louisianisation correctement et je
les mêmes écrits produits c'est le but
c'est une arme à deux tranchants si
c'est là que le québec s'en va dans le
canada ça donne des munitions parti
québécois à perdre et écouter on a
besoin d'un vrai projet de société
indépendantistes et ça donne des
munitions aux libéraux qui vont dire
vous voyez il prépare des scénarios
catastrophe pour faire un référendum à
n'auriez pas intérêt vraiment aller de
ce côté le calendrier juridique parce
qu'une intervention fédérale sur la loi
96 la loi maintient et certainement un
effet sur la campagne électorale en
principe le calendrier juridique ne
permet pas au gouvernement et on pense
pas que le gouvernement du canada va
faire un point de presse pour annoncer
qu'ils s'en vont en cours contre le
québec pendant la campagne électorale
pendant qu'alexandre duval vous êtes à
tout à côté de ces magnifiques chutes
montmorency et l'autobus de campagne
arrive
absolument monsieur legault qui arrive à
bord de son autocar de campagne vous le
voyez donc le timing est bon comme on
dit pour se parler patrice à cette heure
ci on est aux abords de la chute
montmorency on a vu toute une ribambelle
de candidats débarqué il ya quelques
instants geneviève guilbeault est ici
bernard drainville est ici éric caire et
si martin biron et si également loges je
pense avoir aperçu aussi ian lafrenière
alors voyez pour ce premier
rassemblement pour ce lancement de
campagne
on a décidé de sortir plusieurs gros
canons c'est le discours au cours duquel
monsieur legault va donner le ton à sa
campagne donc il nous parlera assurément
de ses priorités économie environnement
éducation santé identité il l'a effleuré
un petit peu plus tôt ce matin que sa
campagne tournerait autour de ces thèmes
là mais on ne prévoit pas d'annoncés
particulièrement aujourd'hui on est
vraiment dans la démonstration de force
on est dans un rassemblement militant et
ce sera d'ailleurs ce que monsieur
legault fera plus tard aussi en journée
au saguenay parce que l'on fait un petit
arrêt aux abords de la chute montmorency
mais ce sera pas tellement long qu'on va
reprendre la route pour filer vers le
saguenay parce que la coalition avenir
québec a les yeux bien river je vous le
dis depuis le début de la journée mais a
les yeux bien rivés sur la
circonscription de jonquière au saguenay
qui est la seule circonscription que la
coalition avenir québec n'a pas su
décrocher lors de la dernière élection
de 2012 dans la région du saguenay et
lorsque la caq souhaite dans cette
région là cette fois ci c'est un
balayage alors voyez on est en attente
de monsieur legault les gens de l'équipe
de sa campagne qui commence à sortir
petit à petit patrick j'en profite
peut-être pour vous dire que ce matin
lorsqu'il sera et vers le bureau du
lieutenant-gouverneur
on a demandé à monsieur legault
qu'est-ce qu'il souhaitait pour cette
campagne si quelles étaient ses attentes
ou plutôt quel était son objectif il
leur répond d'une majorité donc une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale ses 63
députés c'est quand même un contraste
avec ce que monsieur legault disait à la
fin de la dernière période de travaux
parlementaires il disait qu'il voulait
une majorité forte et un moment donné il
avait même évoqué lors de son bilan de
la période de travaux parlementaires
qu'une majorité forte pour lui ça